i see wokism as a desire to create these
types of
[Music]
desire to create a kind of structure
which will supposedly bind us together
right i see a lot of the covert measures
as a desire to do that as well you know
i see i see things of people trying to
do that but because they are
not grounded in the ancient stories they
don't they don't understand they don't
have a kind of mythical underpinning
that is
that has been developed for millennium
millennia then they they're they're
creating monsters they're frankenstein
uh
creations
we're in total agreement about that but
but so so i what i what i believe is
that
i i believe that
let's say for me let's say being the
best christian i can be
and and living with my family and my
neighbors and the people around me in
the best way that's the first best thing
i can do
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast i have the distinct honor and
pleasure of sitting today with jonathan
pajot who is an artist specializing in
orthodox christian art
he is also maybe more importantly to us
a deep philosophical scholar on
religious questions and
the interface between religious thought
and
scientific and philosophical thought
welcome jonathan it's great to to talk
to you finally after these two years
where we had that first conversation
it's good to be back in the seat
now wait a second two years
i would have said based on you know just
sort of a loose sense of how long it
feels i would have said more like
17 years yeah it's only been two years
no it was i did my memory serves me
correct it was in 2017.
20 that's more than two years that's
more than two years
it's not quite the 17 it feels like but
yeah it is more than two
um yeah well we did have a very
good
brief conversation you and i met on a
panel
uh john
uh our good friend jordan peterson was
on that panel with us and we had an
exchange
at the uh what was it the students for
liberty free speech
like a free speech student association i
think in vancouver
yeah it was a an excellent little
conversation and it did suggest that
there was a whole lot more that needed
to be discussed and
we have come close to having that
conversation several times in the
intervening 17 years but have not gotten
there until today so
let's orient the audience a little bit
my audience knows that i don't exactly
do interviews that really what happens
on dark horse are conversations between
people who have something about which
discussion is necessary and you and i
very definitely do because
i have been
coming from an evolutionary perspective
looking at religion and
trying to understand it and as you know
i've put put forward a model that
explains how
adaptive evolution would have created
such a thing i believe the model is
uh almost certain to be accurate in the
broad brushstrokes the fine detail
obviously
um
you know could take uh many lifetimes to
sort out but in general what i've argued
is that religion is literally false
metaphorically true and that what
metaphorically true means is that those
who behave according to
the wisdom in religious
doctrine out-compete those who behave
according to the falseness of that
doctrine and that that explains why
these things spread it's basically a
counterpoint to the new atheist idea
that
that religion is effectively a mind
virus that it is a parasite traveling at
expense to to humans
now
that has had various impacts uh in
science by and large
darwinists are slow to accept that any
such explanation might exist
interestingly religious
scholars have
i would say none of them have embraced
the notion but many have been willing to
play ball and to talk about what its
meaning
might be and you're certainly one of
them so what i'm hoping to do with you
today is to talk about the question of
what religion is whether or not the
picture that you see coming from a
religious perspective and the picture
that i see coming from a scientific
perspective are actually the same
picture just viewed from a different
angle i don't know the answer to that
question i'm curious as to what what you
will say
and then the question the one that i
think is really important is
given the picture that we can agree on
whatever the you know the overlap may be
what is its implication for how we
should view
these questions that have historically
been cast in religious terms what is it
that we moderns should do in light of
the information about what what we
now seem to know
yeah that makes a lot of sense yeah i'm
that i mean i think that's a
conversation i was hoping to have with
you so that sounds great
great um anywhere in particular you you
want to start
um i think that maybe i can
because i've heard your your explanation
about you know the function of religion
that's there the the theory of religion
and
the way that i like to present religious
pattern is is maybe a lot wider than the
way it is presented socially i tend to
think of i tend to actually not like the
term religion as a very specific very
narrow type of behavior that we have and
i like to understand religion in general
as the manner in which we bind together
that is the things that we do as humans
to to bind us together
uh into into groups in general
bind us together towards higher purposes
is maybe the best way to understand it
that is we organize our behavior in a
certain manner which makes us able to
exist as higher
beings or higher units when i say higher
beings i mean you know families
countries uh
higher but that is also analogous to the
manner in which we cohere inside
ourselves because a human being is also
made of different parts and different
aspects different thoughts different
desires different there's all these
things competing inside us for supremacy
you could say or for attention and the
manner in which we cohere those aspects
together will be part of what we tend to
call religion which is why religion has
a individual aspect whether it's prayer
worship meditation depending on the
different religious practices but then
that scales up to the social level well
you'll have a type will have ritual
behavior you'll have sacrifices you'll
have a common worship uh you know uh
circumambulation of important places or
important things that we that bind us
together
so that is
more so the way that i understand
religious practice because it seems to
to to encompass
more clearly what it is like what what
it is we're doing
at all the different levels at which we
do them
so
would it be all right if i put a couple
tools on the table sure um
first i want to start
with the question
of faith in science because i really
think one of the one of the reasons that
people
misunderstand
the status of
religion however we describe it
when it comes to scientific explanations
is that we do not do a fair job of
correcting
for
the way scientists work on other
questions and i think the the more i
think about this the more important i
think it is
when i talk to most scientists about the
question of faith
it turns out that most scientists have
the belief
that they are functioning without any
faith at all
and
they you know there are exceptions to
this there are scientists who
very often have to be careful in their
academic context not to speak too
publicly about it there are scientists
who do have a separate faith right they
go to church or temple or whatever it
might be
but they tend to see
faith as something absent from their
scientific practice now to me
this
seems absurd i don't think you i
literally think it is impossible to do
scientific work without any faith
and
basically i would argue
that
you have to
faith are things that you take without
evidence
the fact that you are
a being that is capable of of observing
a universe which it is necessary that
you are in order to do scientific work
is something you cannot prove and yes we
can say well descartes proved it but i
don't think he really did i think what
he did is he took the first
cheat and he said let's just assert that
i exist and that i know because i'm
thinking
and go from there and my point would be
if you really scrutinize descartes proof
you will discover it's not a proof it's
a leap of faith
and if you don't make it then you will
literally spend your entire career
attempting to solve this unsolvable
puzzle which will be a waste of time
because you won't do it
or you can make that leap of faith and
you can say assuming that i am a being
who can observe the universe then here
is the science that i'm going to do and
so
to make a long story short
scientists work to minimize the amount
of faith necessary in the explanations
of the universe that they come up with
but you cannot bring it to zero
and
if we then move from there to this
question of things that are literally
false but metaphorically true
these things are features of every
scientific model that we have that is
incomplete right and you know
darwinism is extremely incomplete
because it's so new and so complex our
models get more complete as we go into
chemistry and physics the simpler
realms but the point is all of these
things involve
places where our explanations aren't
very good and where we fill in some
feature of the model that we cannot
demonstrate but that functions well
enough if we operate on the basis of it
so
what i'm getting at is
religions may be largely based on
literally false metaphorically true
beliefs and science starts out based on
those things and whittles them away but
can never get to zero but really these
two realms have the same characteristic
which is that they depend on us being
able to skip certain
levels of explanation in order to to do
the job of the whole
all right so i'm going to put you a
little on the faith thing or what faith
is
the way that i
faith is the trust in things that are
unseen
that is
at all levels of analysis
the level which is be above it
is unseen from that level
okay so what i mean is that
if you're analyzing something at a
molecular level you can never see the
apple
you'll see its constituents if you go
down same problem if you go up same
problem if you're talking about the
apple and an orchard if you're looking
at the level of the apple you'll never
see the orchard
and so what faith is is that move
between levels because from the level in
which you are
you if you only take the elements given
to you at that level and you analyze
them
there's no jump
to the higher identity that jump is
always a leap of faith once you have it
then you can analyze things at that
level that is once you reach that higher
level once you for example if you if you
look at the people in
in a
in a mass
you can't see the city you have to jump
up until you see the city once you have
the city then you can use that identity
and compared to other cities and
compared to other levels at this at the
at the same level but you in the way
that our
mind or our experience tends to work is
that we can see parts of things and we
can see holes of things and we can
notice that things are made of parts and
also have unity but the jump from the
parts to the unity is one which is which
is not accessible at the level of the
parts
now i
i'm not sure about this um because i
think there are many
places especially in biology
where
at one time we couldn't see the jump
between levels but we figured it out
and now we can and so what you're saying
if i understand you correctly
is that the jump between levels is
always one of faith and i would argue
that it tends to start as an article of
faith it's faith from the level from
that level that is it it's faith if you
take the elements of that level
within those elements it's always it's a
jump it's a leap
into another level of being and so that
is the that is you could say something
like the trust in things unseen which is
that if you're if you're at a certain
level you can't see
you can't see above until you do that
and once you're there then you see but
you can't see until you're until you
make that jump
darkhorse has a new sponsor the
spectator
as the longest-running magazine in the
world the spectator issues identity
politics in favor of intelligent
conversation and thought
from the war in ukraine to the
ideological war in the classroom from
the rise of inflation to the rise of
cancel culture the spectator has been
dedicated to stimulating reporting and
analysis since 1828.
the spectator also covers the best in
books travel food wine and much much
more
the u.s edition of the spectator has
recently come ashore and is bringing its
high quality writing and analysis to u.s
audiences for the first time and we have
a special offer for listeners of
darkhorse
sign up today and you'll receive three
free months of the print magazine and
full digital access
plus they're going to send you a free
spectator hat that no one can stop you
from calling a sombrero
just go to spectatorworld.com
special offer and use the code darkhorse
personally i'm a fan of the spectator
because it is committed to the quality
of its reasoning and writing not to a
particular political party or ideology
it's got marvelous contributors
including douglas murray lionel shriver
julie bendel christopher buckley roger
scrutin and dark horse's own heather
heing
the spectator is less political party
more cocktail party whether you lean
left or right you are guaranteed to be
entertained informed and enlightened
from cover to cover
so sign up today and get three months of
the spectator for free plus a hat
subscribe today at spectatorworld.com
special offer
use offer code darkhorse at checkout to
redeem the offer that's
spectatorworld.com
special offer and use the code darkhorse
well i have i have a good example to to
test this out
depending upon how willing you are to
step into the
biology we'll see depends how
complicated it is we once did not know
how information
was stored in a cell so darwin described
the process by which information is
refined by selection but he didn't know
where the information was stored and
there was of course a famous
battle
protein seemed a likely place where
information could be stored dna seemed
distinctly less likely because it had
less variation to it it was a de popper
alphabet
but it turned out the dna
was the primary repository for
information we now know that the story
is much more complex than this but
uh to the extent that triplet codons
described series of amino acids and
those amino acids do the functional work
of the cell they make effectively
machines inside the cell enzymes that
put together
uh
atoms that might not
bind at normal energies otherwise for
example
we now know
what
brings the protein level and the
informational level
together
right so at one time it would have been
an article of faith but now
it is not whereas
the
story that we tell evolutionarily about
um
most mutations are bad changes in
spelling in the dna
occasionally one results in a change in
a protein that's good those protein
changes that are good accumulate because
selection favors them and that changes
the form of organisms and can ultimately
change something that has the form of a
shrew into something that has the form
of a bat
right that story
i would argue actually contains an
article of faith that isn't true there's
a missing layer of
explanation that we scientists assume
must be there but actually isn't we
there there's something in the
explanation of just simply missing
so but i think you're misunderstanding
what i mean by by faith or by the jump
of level so
let let's take let's take the the dna
for example
so you have
you have a bunch of stuff right i'm not
a scientist you have a bunch of stuff a
bunch of acids you have a bunch of stuff
that's there and then then all of a
sudden you
are able because we're conscious beings
you're able to perceive a pattern
that pattern is repeated
in different cells
but that pattern has an existence of its
own
because you can abstract it and you can
model it
and so it doesn't only exist in the
cells it has it has an invisible
existence a pattern a pattern existence
and so that pattern
is an unseen in the sense that it's not
a bunch of stuff it's a pattern of a
bunch of stuff now that that pattern
like i said can be modeled but the jump
between the bunch of stuff and the
pattern that is what i talk about when i
say
faith that is because
it's the same at every level of being
like i'm using the lowest level but it's
it's sometimes it's harder for people to
see it at that level but it's a lot
easier if you move up to things like
cities and families and and and let's
say
troops of armies or all of these things
where all of a sudden you see a
structured cohesion of beings that come
together into a pattern
but that pattern like i said is it can
is is invisible because it it can be
modeled and then reproduced it has all
this type of of has these types of
qualities
so basically i'm arguing for the
existence of patterns and that's
ultimately where i'm not i don't want to
hide it from you that's why i'm bringing
you to what religion is is that it's the
patterning of being all right so we are
clearly in the phase where we have to
teach each other our
language in order to have a conversation
i fully agree that there are patterns in
fact i have argued and will argue that
the only thing that is amenable to study
is patterns that's what we study um and
that these patterns exist at different
levels right i would call and i've heard
you use the term so i
i know we at least have a shared term
here
the jump between levels is emergence
emergence can be
one of these articles of faith that i
described where we cannot explain
why
the properties of the higher level uh
are
viewed based on the properties of what
exists at the levels below it
right so yeah now we're on the same now
we're in the same direction definitely
now we're in the same direction so and i
would understand and you know i'm not
i'm very interested in the philosophy of
science but i'm not a philosopher of
science but
i take it that there are two ways of
understanding
emergence there are those the strong
emergentists who believe that there is
no
you cannot explain
uh the jump
in emergence between
many different levels
i would describe myself as a weak
emergentist which is to say i believe
that uh
you we may never have the computing
power to do it but that in principle
everything at the higher levels ought to
be explainable by the properties of
things at the lower levels if you
comprehend it well enough
you know is there a
discontinuity at the very bottom you
know original cause something like that
i think i have to leave that possibility
open but in general there shouldn't be
irreducible
levels of emergence at higher
higher stages of explanation
but all right so let's let's try to
figure out
where we've
landed
let's take
i can add maybe something to help you so
just so that we're not so that i don't
we don't lose ourselves so the manner in
which i try to describe to describe it
is a two-way
process that is i understand why
scientists and materialists they like to
talk about emergence bottom up but i
think that talking about emergence
bottom up will always lead you into to
some it will lead you into some problems
and so let's say the t the normal
religious point of view would be that
there's there's something we use the
word emanation we could use other words
there's an emanation from the pattern
and there's emergence from
the constituents and so there's there's
a causality of pattern that is patterns
are causal they they they affect they
affect order and so we can it's it's
hard to see like i said in biological i
think it's still true but it's easier to
see in human structures whereas you have
a military captain that orders and that
order
goes down the order of of causality and
creates action in the men that are
digging trenches or that are doing
whatever they're doing and so but that
wouldn't be possible without the
emergent principle of these men together
with a single with a common purpose that
are bound by this hierarchy into into
action and so there's a top-down there's
a top-down causality which is different
than the bottom-up causality but those
two
those two come together and that's what
anyway it's important because when we
get to rituals and when we get to
to uh to uh let's say uh hygiene laws
it's gonna be important to understand
that because it it it feeds into why
those things are important okay so let
me use an example here which uh it does
double duty um
in my field
i believe my colleagues have been slow
to understand the darwinian nature of
religious
belief and religious faith
because they have a
missing level of analysis
right in general
we can talk about
the evolution and divergence of species
right we have a language for that and we
can talk about the
nature of individuals
but uh it has been long contentious in
my field what the status of groups is
and
interestingly the
uh the by the evolutionary biologists
who have focused on adaptation right
which is understood to be a property of
individuals right the individuals
manifest the
adaptations that level of analysis has
been inconsistent with understanding
religion because religion is not a
property of the individual individuals
manifest aspects of it but obviously
catholicism is not an individual and so
to the extent that your toolkit for
adaptive evolution is built around
properties of individuals or maybe tiny
little kin groups
you you don't see its nature
the folks who have done the best with
understanding religion in evolutionary
terms are the group selectionists who i
believe are actually
um
using an article of faith that is
literally false in order to skip to the
level at which you can look at a group
and see its behavior as adaptive which
it is
now what they're looking at is not in
fact a group they've misunderstood the
mechanism but by allowing themselves the
article of faith that maybe we can talk
about adaptation of something smaller
than a species and larger than an
individual
right they
have
uh they've built a bridge that allows
them to walk into human cultural
evolution and see that it often evolves
over
large numbers of people which they
mistakenly describe as a group right so
faith is playing a role in science there
it's interesting because
why do you why do you believe that a
bunch of cells working together
is
has and and forms an individual has more
reality than a bunch of individuals
acting together in a group like why is
it that one is more real than the other
that's like i'm not even a scientist and
i wonder why would anybody think that
it's a great question and the answer is
because we know exactly why the cluster
of cells behaves in the way that it does
because the genomes in each of those
cells is identical and especially when
we talk about something like an animal
if effectively the cells in your eye
have to collaborate with the cells in
your liver in order to allow the your
gonads to pass on your genes and so what
there is in in a creature is perfect
agreement on what the objective of the
exercise
is
that does not exist
in a cluster of individuals but the
question is can you figure out to what
extent it does exist and why and so we
have several different uh i would now
say that they are theories they started
as hypotheses they are now well enough
established to be theories
about why cooperation
exists when you don't have identical
genes or
disproportionately similar genes
so we have
uh
kin selection which i just described
similar genes driving collaboration we
have reciprocal altruism i scratch your
back if you scratch mine and we have
indirect reciprocity where i participate
in a collective in which my back gets
scratched and your back gets scratched
but it may not be
an exchange right
so we have those
those theories of collaboration what we
don't have is a theory of collaboration
that scales up properly to things like
um
like catholicism or judaism or
or islam
right we don't have that and so
what that what that results in is too
much skepticism
amongst evolutionary biologists that
these things are in fact adaptive
so i have a so
my big question is this is that i think
it seems that one of the problems which
is making it difficult for people to
to be able to bridge that is because
they continue to understand survival at
the individual level and then try to see
how that survival could be maximized by
a group but what they're not they're not
doing is seeing it at the right level
which is that you're not so you
shouldn't look at the survivability of
the individual you should look at the
survivability of the group and how it
perpetuates itself and then how it
reproduces itself into other groups
that's what you should be looking at
because it's like you're skipping levels
on one concept but you're not skipping
levels on the other so here's the
problem with that the problem is uh and
i'm not faulting you for this but when
you use the term group
you artificially hobble your explanation
right what do you mean
um a group is an so again there's a
long-standing battle in my field over
this um but in the late 60s early 70s
this got sorted out and then it has been
unsorted out in more recent decades but
what was sorted out um by
by my intellectual ancestors was
that although
if you take two groups
right just actual clusters of
individuals
um
a group of altruists
will out-compete a group of individuals
who are selfishly motivated everybody
agrees on this yeah the problem is that
if you introduce a selfishly motivated
individual into one of these groups of
altruists that individual will
out-compete other individuals within the
group and so groups don't evolve because
they are taken apart by a collective
action
conundrum inside the group right
now what this leaves us with
is a world full of things that look like
groups that appear to collaborate
for which we do not have an explanation
and my argument would be and i think
much of what you've said is quite
accurate
that these things that look like groups
the ones that are
evolutionarily robust are actually
lineages
okay and a lineage is not a group
subject to that same uh tension between
individual and collective well-being
a lineage is actually something that
selection can act on and so the point is
selection there can turn the tables on
the individual who would profit at the
expense of
the other members of
the collective
and it can produce larger level adaptive
phenomena like religions so
um in any case all i would argue is
what you're calling a group
is actually a lineage and because it's a
lineage it has evolutionary it has an
evolutionary nature that is not present
in something that would actually be a
group right
i mean what i'm what i'm calling a group
is
any
any let's say what we call individuals
like any individuals that are acting
together towards a common purpose that's
what i call a group and so for me like
my theory applies to google and
and facebook as much as it applies to
families that it applies to countries
that is as it applies to any type of co
any type of
space where
different individuals are aligned
themselves towards a purpose
and some groups are more functional than
others obviously some groups are less
and some groups will tend to devour its
members you know and some groups will
tend to make them flourish
and that there are different ways in
which
ways to set that up so that it's the
most
coherent let's say and the purpose is
the survivability of the group itself
right but this is exactly the problem is
that if you if you take a a
hypothesis robust enough to explain
something
like uh
catholicism
and you say well
google has a lot of the properties of
you know a collective that uh engages
you know of a congregation
right
and it does indeed it has many of those
properties but it doesn't have all of
them and what you will see is that they
behave differently over time precisely
because of this issue about the
individual who behave selfishly
in
a group
profiting at the expense of the group
right so ultimately you would expect
things like
google
uh to fail to function in a coherent
fashion and in fact i would argue we are
seeing that we are seeing the in the
incentives of the individuals who decide
what google does
betraying
google right they are actually hobbling
the entity uh to enrich themselves which
is exactly what you would expect and you
don't see that
in a
a
an ancient religion you may see it in a
cult or something that has just emerged
but something that has stood the test of
time will have stood the test of time
because it has structures in it that
prevent that from happening
yeah well the the way that i like to
talk about that is
that it has to do with purpose like this
is difficult because obviously
purpose isn't difficult in terms of
directed action maybe is the best way to
like a way to use a word that's more
scientifically appropriate and so
depending on the directed action it will
also
affect the structures that will set
themselves up you know
in the way what's going to happen in
that group and so one of the things that
religion has done in different religions
is to try to identify the highest
direction for action and so in terms of
christianity the high or point of
attention we can use the word point of
attention because attention is what
directs action and so in christianity
the highest point of attention is
something like the infinite
source of the world which is also love
and so that is our
point of attention and so we bind
ourselves together
in that
in the direction towards that point so
what will happen is sometimes
parasitical systems will set themselves
up that's inevitable it's going to
happen but because the the point of
attention is something like the the
infinite source of the world and and
that it is bound in love then they'll be
self self uh repairing mechanisms which
will also be part of that group because
at some point the
there'll be a judgment right you'll
notice that the leader is not in line
with what the group is supposed to be
and so there'll be some mechanism to
eliminate the the parasite but in google
there's none of that like in these
massive corporations there it's only to
make money it's only to to to grow your
your your riches and so you don't you
don't have those mechanisms set up
but
so
my point is there's a reason you don't
have those mechanisms set up and it's
because evolution does not favor their
emergence in the context of google
whereas it does in the context of um of
a
of a religion or like an a a more
coherent religion let's say right and so
what i really
what i really hope that you will be able
to hear from me is that actually an
evolutionary perspective and i know you
take evolution seriously i've heard
talks with other people that you've done
in which you raised the issue yourself
so i know you're aware uh of its
relevance but
my point to you would be a proper
evolutionary understanding of religious
phenomena not only explains the nature
of religions
things like mechanisms that frustrate
uh individual profit at the expense of
the collective right those are adaptive
but it also predicts the failure
of religions that do not successfully do
this and it predicts the divergence of
religions
right so
what i'm arguing is it's possible to
overdraw this if you simply say oh
religions are like species right and uh
you know there's a speciation event at
which uh you know christians depart from
from jews and another one at which
protestants depart
from
from catholics
you know that's true
at one level it is not perfectly
analogous to
genetic speciation
but that if one follows the logic
carefully there is actually a
uh a tool kit that predicts all of these
events and um
describes why some work better than
others that effectively one
understanding what
job is being accomplished by these
structures
tells you how they are likely to behave
in the same way that looking at
organisms and understanding their
ecology predicts how they will respond
to certain kinds of change and so and
when you use a word better what is it
that you're referring to
uh well i would say um
that evolution if we do the work
properly
what evolution what darwinian evolution
favors is lodging a particular set of
genes and i know that word will show up
strangely here but i i will defend it if
need be
lodging a particular set of genetic
spellings as deeply into the future as
possible in other words what selection
favors is the persistence of genetic
spellings
and
that the measure of it is how you know
the duration of that persistence ideally
selection
would favor um indefinite persistence
indefinite persistence is an
unattainable and so it it it basically
shapes things like creatures and things
like lineages such that they
become durable okay so let's use a word
that is maybe more general so you would
say that the process
favors the persistence of patterns
right the persistence of patterns that
persist right like that that that tend
to persist longer and on on than others
or have more
more more capacity to self-perpetuate
yeah except there's a there's a giant
hazard in the way you've just described
it okay so if you uh i uh had a
conversation with with dawkins in
chicago and what must have been 2018
um
and it became clear in this conversation
dawkins is the uh the inventor of the
term meme and the idea of meme is i
regard it as one of the most important
innovations of
the latter half of the 20th century it
is the key to understanding humans but
the way dawkins understands it
memes are an
analogous
space to genes
right
that basically and he in fact in in
chapter 11 of the selfish gene where he
introduces the idea he says that memes
are effectively a new primeval soup
and he says it has similar rules to
the rules that govern the evolution of
genes
now this is an error i don't fault him
for the error you know everybody makes
errors as they introduce an important
new uh hypothesis but he never corrected
it and nobody else did either the
problem is
memes do not have the same status as
genes it's not a parallel realm
memes
cultural evolution is a mechanism by
which genes solve a certain problem
right cultural evolution because culture
can flow horizontally it can evolve much
more rapidly than genes right
genes are setting up a mind in a
creature like a human being that is
amenable to cultural evolution because
that solves a genetic problem
and so
the reason i raise all of this is
when you say okay these patterns these
are patterns that are trying to move or
that selection is favoring their uh
movement into the future my point is
they are not
of symmetrical standing right
and this is i don't you know you will
understand easily but other people will
mishear i'm not arguing that this is
positive in a normative sense but this
is a
an is and not an ought
cultural evolution which is the thing
that makes human beings special or at
least
one of a pair of things that make humans
very special
is
superior
to genes in the sense that it is much
more rapidly evolving but it is inferior
to genes in the sense that it is
evolutionarily subservient to the
objectives of the genomes so
my point is
genes
are
favored to move into the
future
right to lodge themselves as far in the
future as possible that's what selection
favors
it is
selection
is willing to swap out and kill off
memetic patterns that is cultural
patterns in order to lodge genes into
the future right
so that is to say
to take an example if you
move to beijing
right
and
you
get married you have some children your
children will speak mandarin
right they will speak mandarin because
it is in your genes interest for them to
speak the local language fluently right
the part of you that speaks english your
your english speaking nature will not
struggle to survive it will actually
willingly vanish in your children and be
replaced by mandarin so that they can be
effective and this is a general pattern
the
um
cultural traits that we have are means
to a genetic end
right so how so how it do you explain
self-sacrifice in that in that uh
in that structure like how do you
explain a soldier that jumps on a
grenade let's say beautiful
and this is one of the places that uh
group selection is is left spinning its
wheels that lineage selection is not
there are many many circumstances in
history in fact i would argue probably
most circumstances in which an
individual's fitness is not a strong
contributor to how deeply their genes
will be lodged into the future
right if i am a member of
a population
right
and i
let's say i'm a very sick evolutionarily
successful
individual right let's say i
uh you know the normal expectation would
be that a an individual who reaches
a reproductive age would leave two
surviving offspring each of which would
have 50 percent of their genes right
thereby they would replace themselves in
the population that's the average let's
say that i beat that by
um
50 times
okay so instead of leaving two surviving
offspring each of which are fifty
percent like me i leave a hundred uh
offspring who are 50 like me i've done
very very well right
but my population has been rendered
feeble by my behavior my selfish
uh behavior within
this population has made it vulnerable
to its enemies and its enemies overwhelm
it and destroy it
well what's my fitness now
it's zero yeah even though i beat the
odds tremendously
so
what this means and then let's reverse
that example and say okay what about
a lineage in which individuals are
willing to make sacrifices indeed some
will make the ultimate sacrifice in
order to make the lineage strong well
maybe i don't come home from the
battlefield and i never leave any
offspring but the genes that i would
have left are circulating in the
population
that
is more robust for my self-sacrifice and
the point is if we check in on that
population 100 years later a thousand
years later the likelihood that it still
exists because of the self-sacrifice is
higher
right
and so
my point is if you tell that story in a
world of groups
it doesn't work because the individual
who benefits from
the self-sacrifice of another individual
and does not engage in self-sacrifice
himself that individual is actually best
off and the group crumbles because of it
but in a world of lineages that's not
the case in a world how do you how do
you account for that happening in what
you call groups then because
christianity is a good example where
where christianity is not
lineage based yeah it is
and so so if you
let's say
someone who dies for their faith for
example in christianity you know is
is i don't know are they doing it for
their lineage and they're not even
they're
how how would they be doing it for their
lineage that's what i'm arguing that's
that's exactly what i'm arguing right so
if let's take uh a celibate clergy
all right
so a celibate clergy is in a marvelous
position especially i mean you know
catholicism makes this all too easy to
see right if we take a celibate clergy
that is
uh
empowered with certain tools
right um
you're supposed to confess your sins
uh to a clergyman in
in a box that makes it easier for you to
do that you're you're facing them but
you're not exactly facing them right
well that
uh
priest now knows something about who is
betraying whom
within their congregation right
and they're in a marvelous position
to
um give a sermon
that's actually squarely on the money
about what's going wrong and what's more
if let's say we're talking about
adultery right let's say you know
somebody commits adultery with another
member of the congregation
they uh
fear
for their immortal soul they go into the
box they explain
to the priest and if i'm using any of
these terms incorrectly feel free to
correct me
yeah i'm not catholic so it's okay
well still you'll know the terms yeah i
know it works there um but uh
but okay they go in the box they confess
you know father i've sinned i've
committed adultery and then let's say
the other person the person with whom
they committed adultery
doesn't confess all right well now this
priest knows that we've got two problems
we've got an adultery problem in the
congregation and we've got
a
failure to adhere to the confession
obligation
problem so now this priest is in a great
position to give a sermon to scare the
hell out of people in the congregation
hey things that threaten us are going
wrong right
all right so
what this means is
that the
congregation which is composed of people
who are going to be related to each
other at various levels could there be
anybody in the congregation who's
unrelated sure um but in general this
congregation is going to be something
that is going to be you know passed down
in a familial manner
and you've got celibate members of the
congregation that is to say people who
cannot profit by leaving their own
offspring and in fact people who cannot
easily profit um
by
uh monetarily right
who are in a great position to speak for
the interests of the lineage going
forward
right so
my point is that pattern is mirrored
across the entire uh structure that
people behave more collaboratively than
they would otherwise that the
priest is in a position to see the
interests of the lineage and to speak
for it and in fact to speak on behalf of
god and to remind people of the
literally false but metaphorically true
idea that if they do not shape up they
will dwell forever in a lake of fire
after their death if they
do adhere to the terms of the religion
then they will uh live a marvelous uh
heavenly existence after they are gone
right these are very powerful incentives
that cause the lineage to behave more
like an organism than it would otherwise
i mean i think that what you're the
description you give is account for some
aspects let's say but monasticism let's
say monasticism isn't like that you know
a monastery isn't what you're describing
uh
martyr isn't what you're describing that
is there's a sense of self-sacrifice in
christianity which which goes beyond
the the one that you're describing and
that it although your your explanation
accounts for that very well like in
terms of mechanical causes
it there
when you realize that for example
self-sacrifice is a
self let's say self-sacrifice is one of
the pillars of christianity let's say it
that way and the notion that if you
sacrifice yourself
that it is
that it builds the world right it it
holds the world together but that is
true at at all the levels right it's not
only true for the priest the example you
gave is very good but there's a sense in
which
i feel like
you know if you have let's say 12 monks
that live in a monastery that no one
ever sees that they're completely
isolated or the notion of
in the middle ages you would have people
who would be walled in to to churches
and would just be there praying and they
people would just know that they're
there and there would be no interaction
with them no contact with them uh you
know uh
and so
i can maybe sometimes see for example
you can imagine like franciscans who
help the poor like how helping the poor
would do what you're saying but there
seems like there's something
there's something else because
christianity itself which is based on
the notion of someone who died
uh
creates a
i guess what i'm get what i'm getting to
is that i think that your your
explanation it accounts for some parts
of the pattern
of christianity let's say or other
religions but it doesn't account for it
enough
it can pick and choose within this
within the the
phenomena and say well i can account for
that but it seems like it doesn't
account for the totality of it
it because because the totality has a
coherence it's important to understand
it's not an arbitrary bunch of stuff
that that there's a there's a founding
story that founding story let's say uh
comes down into reality and has
variations of it all through its its
story the pattern has the same and so
there's a there's a there's a real
coherence let's say to the way it sets
itself up which i don't think is
accounted for it's not accounted for
but this is the nature i mean you know
i'm coming at this as a scientist and i
recognize that what i've described to
you
is
uh a cartoon at best yeah okay it's a
cartoon which i think is accurate but it
is far from precise and it is not fully
explanatory but then the question is
well what about the things that it
doesn't explain and are there
explanations for those things you know
and it's very much like looking at uh
you know the morphology and physiology
of a body and realizing you know
you know you start with the realization
that uh darwinism
is the explanation for the form in front
of you but that doesn't necessarily
explain to you
how the work of the cells is done right
that takes
that takes a whole different set of
explanations a different level of
explanation
so
i would argue that the place to go next
is to think developmentally right and if
you take the structure that i just
described right that's a structure of
adults
if you take that structure of adults
and you now raise children in the
context of that structure what they do
is they actually take on
the
implied
rules the threats and the rewards that
are described around certain behaviors
they they get written into that child's
being in a way that the child does not
even consider certain behaviors because
they are antithetical to their nature
right and you know
you you and i are
to be perfectly horrible about this
right you and i are
members of a species in which many of
our
male ancestors
will have
engaged in rape
right that means you and i have picked
up the genetic potential but neither you
nor i would
contemplate such a thing right that's
because i'm a christian
because i believe in a pattern which is
beyond the the biological i don't think
so i think it's because you're a
christian but i think that's like the
safety on the gun i think were you
suddenly to lose your christian faith
you would not become a rapist
right you have other things there is
decency in you right right because all
those terms all those terms are are are
let's say terms which i don't think are
accounted for by
simple persistence of the of of uh of
the of uh genetic material well so
let's say there was let's say there was
a society
that
raped and a society that didn't
do you think that
it would make a difference in terms at
the genetic level like would it make a
difference it makes a huge difference
unfortunately and i would argue that um
while
all decent societies drive the penalty
for rape through the roof so that it
becomes
not rare enough but rare
the tables are turned
in warfare
right that because
warfare is
almost always occurring between more
distantly related people right people in
generally in general fight alongside
those with whom they are closely related
against those to whom they are more
distantly related
that
and the
um
harm to the lineage therefore of rape is
reduced that there's an awful lot of
rape that takes place during war and
that is obviously uh better understood
the farther back in history we go
but
nonetheless
yes genes have gotten into the future
that way
yes you and i have inherited genes and
you know it's not just men right it's
not like these genes are transmitted on
the y chromosome there's almost nothing
on the y chromosome you know the genes
of women are transmitted this way too by
men who are closely related to them but
the point is
the
prohibition the mental prohibition
the normative prohibition in your mind
is augmented
by your faith but it is not dependent on
it if i where does it come from
it comes from
uh
a
you acquired it developmentally from a
population that
has an agreement on this
right but if it's not to the advantage
of the genes where does it come from it
is to the advantage of the genes
a population in which
women are
in danger of being raped
whenever they are uh when they find
themselves in the world where uh they
don't have
uh a male protector let's say
right that is not a very functional
society for one thing it is a society
that will squander the
potential that exists in women because
those women will not be able
to uh to reach their potential in a
world where they are constantly
jeopardized by by rape right so the
reduction
in that threat is actually an advantage
of the lineage and the point is that's
not the terms that any of us think about
it in right rape is abhorrent
right the reason that you and i do not
entertain the possibility of rape is
that uh
we don't want it
which again yes religion will help you
see that if you do not see it otherwise
it will threaten you into not raping
because uh you don't want to go to the
lake of fire but it is not dependent on
it right but there are some societies
that do want rape
well it depends what you mean um
raping not your own people you always
rape others you don't rape your own
people because if you rape others then
you you like like you said then you
perpetuate your identity
even if it's in a lesser level you
perpetuate it out into out into other
populations well not even identity what
you do is you
uh place genes into other populations
right which is which then you know again
i'm not defending any of this
normatively but also explains
why uh societies have a very
uncomfortable relationship with their
own women who have been raped
yeah of course yeah that makes a lot of
sense but what i mean is again i still
have the issue of understanding
because you you you you appeal to a
common sense so like a common sense like
of course we don't want this but i i
want that's what i want to push you on
which is that if
if it can be to the advantage of a
lineage to rape then where does it come
from that we would we could you could
imagine a world where you would say that
rape is bad for others like
we're going to stop rape for other other
people raping for sure but we are rape
as much as possible right well no
rape others not not our own people but
rape other other people so we've we've
landed back at this issue of group okay
because
we can imagine right if our population
uh
doesn't want
uh its members raped
but it might get an advantage by raping
members of another population
but we could agree
to a reciprocal uh treaty effectively we
could say look let's take rape off the
table right we will forego the
opportunity to rape others if we will be
protected from rape during warfare right
you could come up with this and in fact
the geneva convention
um
obviously forbids lots of behavior in
warfare that an individual population
would benefit from but the idea is we
all would like to prevent
we don't want our soldiers tortured so
let's just take torture off the table
but the problem is
because it is not based on a lineage
it is feeble and we have watched the
geneva convention come apart as much as
it may be
in our interest to take torture off the
table there's no mechanism to bind
others to it and so basically everybody
now cheats and we have you know we've we
so my question is why do you hold to
that like what is it in you that makes
you
hold to that if you can see the your
argumentation is flawless in terms of
what you're saying but i i still i
struggle i mean you know why i'm pushing
you there it's like this is this is the
this is the crux of the difference
between you and i i would say
no
it's not because so the punch line for
my understanding of all of these things
is actually because of the paradox you
just raised we have to turn the tables
on the genes
the genes have been in charge they've
been in charge of our cultural selves
not directly
right but the basic point is
cultural
features that do not advance the
interest of the genes do not persist
long term right the genes are in the
driver's seat
we have to turn the tables because the
genes do not allow us to do what we need
to do i've heard you say this many times
and and and i think that this is where i
i feel bewildered by what you're saying
because your first
point was that group
meme level group level uh societal level
serves the genes
and now you're saying we need to flip
the table but my question again is from
where if that's true
if that's scientifically true where do
you even get the thought where do you
even get the energy where do you get the
possibility of flipping because i agree
that we should not serve our genes but i
don't unders i know where i know where
mine comes from but i wonder where yours
comes from beautiful
um so the story is a funny one right so
uh
all
evolved creatures have the identical
purpose
right their purpose is to lodge their
genes into the future right everything
from
malaria plasmodium to
uh
you know a red panda they all have the
same purpose
which means it's not a very good purpose
i should point out
what they have using the hard words use
the word good that's fine keep going no
i mean
i mean it in its absolutely normative
sense and i'll tell you at the end of
this i hope you'll see where it came
from all right okay
okay so
all those creatures every creature and
presumably every creature on every other
planet where there are creatures and
which i assume there are um
has the same purpose to get their
informational stuff
lodged as deeply in the future as
possible but
the
ways in which one can lodge one's
informational stuff in our case our
genes deeply into the future vary
tremendously that's what biological
diversity is right it's a diversity of
tools for getting genes into the future
the tool
that we were awarded that made
humans truly special
is consciousness
right what does consciousness do
consciousness
i believe
allows us to take two minds
and to pool
their different understanding of the
world their different kinds of expertise
and to basically
asymmetrically parallel process
difficult puzzles that neither of us
could solve together and then you can
scale that up and you can have a whole
campfire of people parallel processing
difficult problems like how do we
survive in this new habitat that our
ancestors didn't know anything about
right that's a tool it's a means to an
end and the end is let's get our genes
as deeply into the future as possible
however
that tool
allows us to do something which is to
understand
the universe around us in abstract terms
that we can transmit
right so we can have conversations and
what that means is that we are actually
to my way of thinking
we are effectively
robots we are aqueous machines with
aqueous computers on our shoulders that
have discovered that we have a purpose
we cannot defend
right
my purpose is to get my genes into the
future sometimes one gets their genes
into the future by putting some other
population into gas chambers
but i don't ever want to do that in fact
i would rather not be than engage in
that behavior so therefore i'm not
necessarily
the person i am
is not on board with the program which
is get your genes into the future uh by
any means necessary
and what's more
i know that if i talk to other
individuals and i say let me ask you a
question
your purpose is to get your genes deeply
lodged into the future but there are
circumstances in which that is done
with a gas chamber are you on board with
the gas chamber thing or are you not
well i know that the people i value most
highly will say of course i'm not and so
the point is if we really mean that then
what we are effectively we are like the
terminator we have discovered that we
have a purpose and the question is do we
like that purpose and if not what if we
say all right i'm chucking out the
purpose and i'm going to replace it with
one that's actually worthy of me all
right so what if i told you that that
purpose that you that you're describing
the purpose of consciousness like that's
actually
the primary purpose and it honestly has
been that from the moment that humans
can speak and from the moments that
humans have consciousness and that if
you want to understand that then you
will look at religious through that lens
through the lens of people
because you seem to think that that's
happening now
but i don't think it's happening now i
think that
what what people who
what humans have realized a very long
time ago
is that
we have a higher purpose
and how that higher purpose is slowly
forming itself and slowly kind of uh
becoming clearer and clear i mean i
think that we can see that happening
through let's say the history of
religion but i think that that's what's
in religion and that it's something that
has been there from the beginning and if
you if you try to understand religion
only through the perpetuation
of genes but then you tell me we have to
have another purpose which is this
basically you're basically telling me we
need to exist we need to exist together
in love is what you're saying
and so i would say that that's just
that's really what
let's say
at least the the latest religions have
been saying and they they they do argue
about how to do it they argue about
certain aspects of it but there's a
sense in which that's how
that's what religion has been from the
beginning well yes and no i believe that
religions are this looking inward but
they are not this looking outward
because of their lineage nature and so
my real message is
i have no
i think you know you've heard me talk
about it and you and i have talked about
it i have no antipathy for religion
right
i think we have a problem which is that
our religions because they are the
product of evolution are not a good
match for a world in which everything is
novel
but from the perspective of what these
things are they are the key
that allowed our ancestors to get us to
the present right these things that
allowed people to collaborate in these
large lineages
right are the key to our success but we
have come to a point at which we now
have a bunch of religions that are
incompatible
that
you know we can pretend they all say the
same thing but they don't
they say some similar things which is
not surprising there's effectively
convergent evolution that has shaped
many of the beliefs but
in essence i think
and you know this is the bitter pill
when i talk to people who who come from
the religious side of this discussion
is that i think if we are to live up to
the ideals that are contained in the
religions that you're describing
that we actually have to recognize
mechanistically what these things are
and say all right how do we do that over
all of humanity and you know maybe maybe
buddhism
gets us there maybe or at least versions
of buddhism
have this sort of highest level of
enlightenment in which we not only view
our own religious
perspective as
uh viable but we recognize the unity of
of of
others but i don't think i i basically
think jonathan that if we
do not recognize
the
underlying evolutionary explanation for
the nature of these belief systems and
then abstract it so that we can have one
for the entire human lineage that we
will destroy ourselves as a result of
the failure of groups to durably cohere
right so let's say even only as an
evolutionist let's say you would you
apply that to any other level of reality
a single coherent pattern like you
wouldn't you don't think that that
there's a need for diversity that
there's a need for oh i didn't say that
that if you create if you create single
patterns that let's say it
encompass all all
then you're creating fragility
no no no um
first of all it may be again you know
you start out with the cartoon level
right so i've described that we need
some sort of abstraction of all of the
religious principles that can cover all
of humanity and yes that could be some
uh homogenization process in which
uh we all become
one not very interesting thing which is
obviously not the world i want to see
but it could be
that um
there are some movements in that
direction by the way
like in in in these world
structures that people are trying to set
up there is a strange flavor for
a kind of homogeneity a weird
universal homogeneity
well
look let me let me steal man it for a
second i don't want it right i'm
somebody who
i
the best parts of me
were informed by
travel to really far-flung places and
the connection with people who had a
very different experience than mine so
believe me i do not want to see the
world made
homogeneous
because i think it will be a tragic loss
there's an argument though
that
we have to do some of that
in other words
what if we understood
that
the key
to reaching an agreement that allows our
descendants to be here a thousand years
from now
is that we must have a shared language
right now i know there are obviously you
know there's esperanto and people have
made arguments along these lines before
but
um
i wonder if it isn't true
that we actually cannot afford
the loss of meaning between
languages like you know russian chinese
english portuguese spanish that as we
try to explain our position
we get a loss of resolution as we move
between these languages and that we can
no longer afford it that yeah you know
with the level of firepower we have the
level of integration of our systems we
just simply put ourselves in existential
danger by allowing that to persist which
doesn't mean anybody needs to stop
speaking any of those languages but it
might mean that we need to prioritize
getting a common language for all of us
so let me i mean let me give you because
you said you seem to think that that the
religions haven't thought of this or
it's not part of their structure but in
in christianity and in islam and in some
ways in judaism and then i think in
other traditions as well there's
something which we call eschatological
reality that is there is an image of
an endpoint or an image of a point where
all is together all is revealed and that
has a structure it's not arbitrary
there's a way in which it's represented
and it's represented as usually as a as
a mountain or a natural place which is
surrounded by a technical place so the
new jerusalem for example in revelation
is described as a tree with water
surrounded by a wall that is made of
stones and and that is technical
and that it says that the glories of all
the nations are carried into the city
right and it's this is what you you're
describing so it doesn't mean that the
nation cease to exist
but it means that the best of all is
carried into unity and that this is how
unity exists unity exists through the
unity doesn't
destroy
the levels this is what true unity
doesn't do it doesn't it doesn't tend to
it doesn't suck in all the levels of
reality into it it tends to exist
like a traditional world works with the
existence of families communities
villages the king the pope right all of
these co-exist they don't have to they
don't have to uh obliterate each other
as they're manifesting themselves at the
different levels so i think that this
image is there it's there but it's there
in understanding that there's a man in
which it cannot be attained
in the world and that trying to attain
it creates another image which is
something like the tower of babel which
is a very fragile you know universal
structure
uh that that is 10th tries to be
all-encompassing a good example of that
is all these projects of digital
identity that we're seeing like these
these types of centralization of
identity of of all your your elements
into one giant world system is something
which has been definitely warned about
in christianity you know we talk about
the number of the beast or the 666 all
these things that people think are weird
and just arbitrary but they're not at
all they're really talking about the
difference between a normal existence of
all these levels of reality coexisting
together and one which is this one
system that tries to let's say permeate
all aspects of reality and tries to
colonize all the elements that which are
below it um and so there is a vision for
that you know we it's just that people
aren't don't struggle to think
imagistically and so because of that
they don't see that it's there but it's
definitely described in the in the bible
itself well all right so
evolutionarily speaking we have
two general ways in which the same
pattern can show up in two places
right one
is
homology which means that you picked it
up from a shared ancestor
and the other is analogy which
effectively means you evolved it
separately for the same reason
right
both of these things exist for religion
so
the golden rule for example
shows up in christianity
from
jesus
and it shows up in judaism through rabbi
hillel
and we can discuss whether or not those
two examples are
both derived from a shared
previous
possibly uncaptured
ancestor something that wasn't recorded
by history or whether this is an
analogous discovery
but the other thing is that in the case
of something like religion because it is
housed in
cultural information rather than genetic
information it can also move
horizontally
and so
um
if you if you do this work carefully you
realize that there was a
something like a speciation event
that
christianity evolved from judaism
right
it basically that's a divergence
and
you know there are vastly more
christians on earth today than there are
jews but that's something that happens
uh
you know
yeah well it's partly because
christianity is universal in its in its
structure it's not based on lineage
actually which is what i one of the
things that i'm trying to argue with you
is that your pattern of christianity can
reproduce itself all over the world
where judaism has a
national lineage-based uh reality which
cannot in indefinitely reproduce no i i
quite disagree with you i'm open to the
possibility you know more than i do
about christianity and that you'll
compel me of this but basically what i
see
is a
adaptive radiation
of christian traditions right so
there is uh
roman catholicism and then there are
various versions of catholicism
that believe in the doctrine but abandon
the obligation to the pope
right um
you know i mean they're yeah they're
from the beginning there are many
different traditions there's ethiopians
there were nubians there were coptics
armenians uh are these people that are
not in any way connected to rome but i
mean whatever that that's fine
they picked up the tradition somewhere
so my point is what we see are two
patterns overlapping which i think are
confusing right we see the ability of
culture to move horizontally and that
can result you know two people who were
not
related at all could both have heard
jesus
speaking and both have started versions
of christianity right and those would be
two separate lineages but the people
those two separate lineages would have
passed this belief system on to
relatives
to descendants
and then it doesn't mean people can't
join but basically my point is you can
map the logic of lineage onto
christianity and if you think in
biological terms in some sense and i i
think actually
this is
reasonably uncontroversial right we talk
about judeo-christian beliefs right
christians are
descended
christianity is descended from judaism
and then it radiates into many different
traditions right
and it uh you know obviously protestants
are christians
right but they are not catholics
right so these are all
you know basically you could draw a
phylogeny of these things
and when you say but christianity is not
a lineage i think what you're doing is
you're looking
you're not realizing that lineage
is a fractal property
right a lineage is an individual in all
of their descendants
and what that means is that you can have
you know within a large lineage you have
many smaller lineages and you can have
the divergence of belief systems
within these smaller lineages and you
know at some level you would expect
christians to be united
uh
against uh
more distant
uh human lineages but to be fractious
when it comes to uh disagreements
uh within christendom
does that make sense no it makes sense
so let's say
because
i think i think that
i think that maybe it's just because the
way that i you i view reality very
differently maybe maybe from you to me
it's like i feel like you always have to
hold on to the genes which is which is
fine like i i i get it but to me genes
are patterns self-replicating patterns
that exist at a certain level and that
there are self-replicating patterns
all through
the different levels of being and that i
don't
feel like i have to prioritize one
rather than the other
like i don't understand what makes
so so when i look so if when you what
you're doing what you're doing it you
you have to it seems like you have to
run around a lot but if you
let me just finish what i'm saying sure
if you understand it for example you
have a a pattern a being and that being
is
self-replicating to a certain extent or
or creates children in the world then
you can understand the spread let's say
of christianity very
easily it just makes sense you have the
the reason why missionaries from greece
would go from constantinople would go to
work would go to russia or the reason
why you know you would have
uh christians in ethiopia or
in all these different places you can
understand how these these these
patterns will reproduce um
and why there's because
for me what makes it difficult is that
how do you account if you're talking
about lineages then where where is is
house the commonality between all these
different living limit inline ages like
where is it housed
what is it well
like where are those patterns like you
know they're obviously not in the genes
anymore now they're right right right
they're housed at a higher level like
these patterns at higher levels they
exist they they're not just
uh let's say
i don't know what what else how else to
say it well let me let me
the simple answer to your question is
they are definitely not housed in the
genes there may be a predisposition
towards a religious viewpoint in the
genes but what is housed in the genes is
extremely limited
what you are talking about is housed in
culture and here's the thing that people
miss culture is special it evolves
rapidly because it can move horizontally
most culture moves vertically
right the more durable a piece of
culture is the more likely you are to
have inherited it vertically and so yes
you do have this very interesting
pattern of people you know
spreading the good word right to people
who aren't related to them
and then the point is it will move
vertically down right to descendants
wherever it takes hold and so that does
create lots of seeds of the cultural
belief that are not fundamentally
connected lineage-wise but then the
question is why
why
does a lineage engage in a expensive
behavior of sending missionaries out
into the world to spread the word and
the answer is i believe because it
creates a hospitable world for
the home lineage right that actually
there's an advantage to it but let me
answer your basic question right
i know i think i know that
you're hearing
my obsession with the genes right as
like a
a defect of perspective
i don't think it is i think the point is
we are unavoidably haunted by the genes
and so i am
vigilant about keeping track of what
role they are playing because to lose
track of that puts us in danger and i
would just say by analogy if we look at
twitter right
and we say well twitter is a place where
people exchange you know perspectives in
small
snippets and they develop an emergent
understanding of the world right
i have forgotten that twitter is also a
business
that
programs opaque algorithms that decide
who sees what and so it's not a place in
which people develop an emergent
perspective it is a place where people
exchange concepts but the way they
exchange them is regulated by an unseen
force and any moment at which you forget
and you think you're just around people
you chose right expressing ideas as you
see fit and them responding as they see
fit any point you lose track of the role
the algorithm is playing in what you see
you've made an error and you're not
going to understand where you are
so my point is that's the genes i'm not
in love with the genes i'm afraid of
what they'll do
and right i'm trying to keep track of
their role in all of our interactions
because i know what they're up to and
it's not good all right okay so let me
let me try to let me try to do something
which which might surprise you a little
bit or
so
my my
what i try to posit is that
we live in these bodies like we have
these experiences and so we we have an
experience of desire we have all these
experiences
we have this sense of the world we have
a we have a you have this embodied
reality in which we live okay
and so
my interpretation always starts
from there
because you don't experience your genes
right right you experience them as
desires you experience them as drives
you experience them as
judgments on others or as a critical eye
on certain things or whatever and so
for me the best way to to represent what
you're saying would actually look more
like a christian
like
ontology which is that
we have certain like christians within
something like you have
desires you have passions and those
passions are dangerous
and if you if you give in to those
passions then you will
die
right let's say spiritually our society
will die all of these things will happen
at higher levels and
if you attach yourself if you attend
to higher things like love if you attend
to virtues then
you will live and your society will live
so
to me that way of describing
is comes
it comes first
and then like all the interpretation of
genes
will will come after because we don't
you you it's
this is this is the
if you talk to people about genes you're
not going to make them change the way
they live oh right right if you tell
them if you tell them don't rape then
that does something
oh like we are don't rape because you
should love your neighbor
and why do you love your neighbor
because if you love your neighbor then
we exist in harmony and peace
you know in the image of the highest
good
which is a god of love let's say so that
will do something but i don't know like
talking to people about genes like if
your purpose is to
to let's say create
the change that you want to create
i don't know um
i don't disagree with you yeah right and
i do think that
look i i want people to understand
genes and biology because i think it's
fascinating
i think it makes for a richer life to
understand what the layers below your
experience are made of and
how it accounts for
your existence
but i am not imagining that anybody is
going to be sold on a new way of viewing
themselves or the world on the basis of
the genes i do want people to have a
proper fear
about the genes and the basic point
would be look
everything
that is
amazing about us
was built
by that genetic layer the things that we
love most about ourselves our ability to
be enlightened our ability to be decent
our moral capacity all of these things
are evolved
right the genes at the very least set
that in motion
many of you say that we have to we have
to topple them
no
it's not like that
okay all of the best things about us
evolved
all of the worst things about us evolved
too and we have to choose that's the
point right i want us to look at the
whole spectrum of what we can be right
from extremely enlightened and decent to
manning gas chambers and i want us to
say you know what
there's a bunch of this i'm just not on
board with no matter what it does for my
genes and there's a bunch of this other
stuff that i'd like to see augmented and
spread as wide as possible and so what
that means is that the genes
can't be in charge anymore because they
will choose both
right if we want the good stuff
then what we have to do is actually say
look
not
you have given us the tools to see
that
the way i have sometimes described it in
is that the
the cosmos is a gigantic spelling bee
that ends in genocide right that's not
where we want to be right and it doesn't
have to be that way but in order not to
be that way we have to look at that
potential and we have to say
no matter what that's off the table we
effectively have to go geneva convention
on the whole puzzle without violating
the math of the situation right but that
that that capacity what you're saying i
mean i this is my understanding it
doesn't seem to
be housed in the genes it seems to be
housed in consciousness right exactly
consciousness the tool the genes gave us
consciousness why to get our genes into
the future and the point is we have to
now say thank you very much
we appreciate consciousness now we're
going to use it for something that's
actually worthwhile
right right but that worthwhile doesn't
come from the genes right
it comes
right it comes from
a higher good let's say you can say it
comes from a higher good i can say the
genes screwed up and they awarded us a
tool that allows us to understand what
they're up to so we can reject it right
but we need it we need a place to stand
from which to reject it like we need a
right but we're standing there you and
me right now right you've got one
perspective which is that there's some
higher force that has allowed us to opt
towards the good well
the higher force thing is going to be a
problem like
maybe maybe because i like it i feel
like this conversation would have to
keep going for another 10 hours for us
to really get to the thing
it's patterns
yes so are higher patterns that one of
the reasons why i i'm really i emphasize
the fact that patterns scale up
is that these patterns they really do
scale up and they're and as they scale
up they manifest the good of that which
they're patterning
okay that's what a pattern is and that's
what's pretty maybe a hard thing for a
lot of people to understand is that
patterns we need consciousness to
recognize patterns right consciousness
is what recognizes pattern but
recognizing patterns is judging pattern
it is always an act of
seeing if something is good
depending on the pattern which is which
it is informing
okay so like when i you know when i'm
looking at a glass i'm always jud
conscious here unconsciously i'm judging
whether it's a good glass can it hold
water can i drink from it and if it
doesn't then it's not fully in line with
its good which is
what what i see it as doing okay from
the point of view from the point of view
of consciousness
and so
that is what
scales up towards really the good that
is the ultimate good
and as we bind together in families we
can perceive through consciousness
we can perceive if we're attentive the
good of our family
but that good isn't enough like you said
because that good can be now put in
competition with the goods of others
like a like a soccer team or you know
baseball team or whatever where you you
can see the good of your team but you're
in competition with others so that
continues to scale like i'm making like
a i'm making a
you know it's a this is a
thomistic argument right this is like a
medieval scholastic argument about the
manner in which things exist which is
that these goods scale up into the
infinite good so it's not a higher force
in the sense of
some kind of weird physical thing that
exists outside the universe it's not
it's a pattern patterns are not the
physical stuff they are that invisible
aspect of things
which drives them towards together which
binds them together you could say the
invisible patterning which makes you see
that they exist
and that's what
scales up into
ultimately a perception of something
like
the infinite love that is behind all
things okay um let me try it from a
different direction all right let's see
okay
can
i believe i can derive from what you've
said that you and i will agree that
consciousness is good because it allows
us
to
understand where we are and to act in
our own interests and that our own
interests involve
something that you and i
would agree is
you know that love is good
and that
more love tends to improve
a system and that we therefore ought to
bias things in the direction of its
propagation
is that fair yeah i said anything that
violates your no no
good all right so
and let us further agree that we don't
really need to defend those things even
if i can't ultimately defend the idea
that consciousness is good i'm just
going to say hey i think it's awesome
and i want i want to use it okay
it's the mechanism by which you even
know something's good so to say that
it's not good is it you're just going to
be running around in circles at some
point you know yep i know that you don't
you would not see the good without
consciousness right so i'm willing to
call it good because for there to be a
good you need the consciousness to even
recognize that there is such a thing so
uh let's just make it let's cheat and
just say it's good let's hard code it as
good
okay
now here's the point
my consciousness is stuck
in space and time
okay
it exists now and it can only see so far
right and it's it's extended i have
history books i can look backwards in
time farther than i could otherwise
without them i can project into the
future by virtue of pooling my
understanding with other people who have
thought about where we're headed and
what will happen but i'm still stuck in
space and time
when i say
i
i am talking about that consciousness
stuck in time but i don't have to be
when i say we
right i could be talking about you and
me
or i could be talking about
our lineage
right we
began farming 10 000 years ago
right
and
the argument i want to make is
morally speaking i believe if
consciousness and love are good
then in some sense i am obligated to do
that which grants consciousness and love
to the maximum number of individuals who
can experience it okay so now i'm trying
to step out of my stuckness in space and
time would you go as far as to say
something like love your enemy like
would you go as far as that i'd say well
i don't don't love your enemy naively
right but yes work to a place where you
and your enemy realize that you're not
really enemies because you both
would like to grant consciousness and
love to as many future people as you can
and that in order to do that
we have to stop fighting in the way
we've been fighting
right and so my my point would be
my consciousness is stuck in space and
time because of the genes
genes granted us consciousness as a tool
and the point is my ability to affect
events 10 000 years in the future
is zero
or presumably very close to it
right i mean it depends
10 000 is long but
at least some people some consciences
have affected a few thousand years for
sure sure sure and look i aspire to it i
would i would love for this conversation
to have an effect on people's viewpoints
from now yeah i mean you know not as a
matter of ego but i just think it would
be cool if we woke people up enough that
actually the conversation had some
resonance but do i really expect this
conversation or anything i ever do to
have resonance ten thousand years down
the line probably not
um probably best not to yeah
but
uh but the point is
because consciousness is a tool of the
genes
it is scaled
to think
uh at
the level that would have been useful to
the ancestors in which consciousness
emerged in other words it makes sense to
think a couple generations down the line
but it doesn't make sense to think a
hundred generations down the line not
because that isn't important but because
you have no ability to impact it
right a hunter-gatherer
who tried to think about how they could
alter their behavior to benefit their
descendants 100 generations later would
have
had no ability to
make any useful change
so it makes sense to be focused on
things that are local to you in space
and time until
you reach modernity
you and i are in a very different
situation right our
insane battling over
modern stuff
actually has strong implications for
whether or not there are human beings
here 10 000 years from now right
in fact it's more likely than not that
there won't be
in order for there to be human beings
here 10 000 years from now we are going
to have to behave very carefully and we
are going to have to figure out how to
preserve the precious opportunity that
we have wherever it came from
so my point is
that consciousness of mine is
artificially stuck artificially locally
right
if selection had been built in creatures
that had impacts 10 000 years in the
future
our consciousness would be scaled to be
able to see ten thousand years in the
future and care about it but we're not
good at it because our ancestors were
limited the power of their tools was
small yeah and so
there's
i think that there are some
consciousnesses human consciousness that
are able to see not ten thousand years
in the future in the in the granular
sense but ten thousand years in the
future in the pattern sense they're able
to perceive
higher patterns great and are able to to
talk about cycles great cycles of being
in great cycles of civilization like
there is a
i don't think that this is something
which has not been available to to
people and the same thing with
consciousness i think that all let's say
all religious practices believe that
consciousness can increase
and that you can increase uh
let's say the the the the capacity of
consciousness to perceive patterns and
to engage in patterns and to transform
patterns right which is why we have
which is why we name things after people
right which is why we have uh patrons of
things like the consciousness can
can become let's say the
guarantors of aspects of reality you
could say
so i think that the way that religion
talks about consciousness team seems to
understand that consciousness is the
point of where
all of this comes together and that it
and that it's working on consciousness
which is more important than the
technical stuff
like like a good a good a good example
is something
you know like that there's a there's a
saying which is in in judaism and in
christianity too right the just the just
holds the world together and the just is
the foundation of the world
and that the idea that
making becoming a better person is the
best thing you can do
for
that to happen
like one of the reasons why we're in the
mess we're in is because we stop just
we started to perceive the world only
materially and that the idea of gaining
material power and gaining
you know gaining power on the world was
the the highest purpose that we could
imagine so we created these massive
technological systems which are driving
us into
madness which are driving us making us
crazy
we've we've actually moved away from the
ideals which held religion together
you know even if religions did bring
about wars brought about some some
horrible stuff you know religions that
religious thinking would has never
brought humanity to the precipice of
destruction like the very existence of
the world being held in the balance uh
whereas as we move away from that and we
we started to think technically
scientifically only then we come to this
point where
we we unleash these golems on the world
that we don't even understand
they're
we can't see the scope of what they're
doing we don't see like i i'm even
willing to give twitter for example the
benefit of the doubt that they didn't
understand the monster they were
unleashing on the world when they did uh
and now we see the golem turning against
its master like in all the ancient
traditions of mechanical beings that
don't
follow the will of their master let's
say um anyways so so i so i'm not sure
like
so i'm not
maybe continue on with what you think
the solution is but i i don't know
first let me say i don't disagree with
what you said i'm sure religions have
sometimes brought their own lineage to
an end bad decision-making will have
been the case but they will not have
brought humanity there you're right
um and the abandonment of religion and
the embrace of full materialism
i agree has clearly brought us there
i will also say we are stuck in space
and time
our consciousness is which doesn't you
know you and i are having a conversation
about
what will be 10 000 years from now right
that is us
trying to bring 10 000 years from now
into our consciousness
but we are in some sense like
um
[Music]
we are using a tool that is not
appropriately scaled right so if you
think about how mount rushmore was
carved
right mount rushmore is a sculpture
right a sculptor uses chisels
and i'm sure there were chisels used in
the making of mount rushmore but there
was also like dynamite
right
and my point is that the
chisel isn't sufficient to make mount
rushmore and our consciousness is going
to need some upgrading if we're going to
pull off the trick of figuring out where
our interests actually are with respect
to the the future 10 000 years from now
right
and so we're basically stuck with
chisels and we need to upgrade to
dynamite in order to get there but
the long and short of it is
we do not think
in terms
of providing a world to our descendants
ten thousand years from now because our
ancestors didn't have an opportunity at
that scale whereas we clearly do
or more likely we have the opportunity
to to
rob our descendants of that future if we
are not careful and so
what i'm really arguing is
if it is our obligation to provide
the opportunity for consciousness and
love to as many descendants as we can
that means an indefinite future for
humanity that means we have to put aside
the lineage against lineage battling
that has shaped humanity it has brought
us this far
but we have to get past it and so
i don't want to see a um
synonymizing of the people of the world
i don't want to see us all be the same
but we do have to reach an agreement in
which the things that cause us to
jeopardize the future
are shelved permanently
in favor of a world that does foster
consciousness love insight
beauty all of the things that we would
agree are
[Music]
inherently or close to inherently good
right and that we're not going to get
there by accident and we're not going to
get there
this is the place where you and i may
differ we are not going to get there by
embracing the traditions that have
arrived in the present but are not built
for it
yeah i mean obviously that's where there
i i disagree uh because i don't see
what i see in the like for example i see
woke-ism as a desire to create these
types of
a desire to create a kind of structure
which will supposedly bind us together
right i see a lot of the coping measures
as a desire to do that as well you know
i see i see things of people trying to
do that but because they are
not grounded in the ancient stories they
don't they don't understand they don't
have a kind of mythical underpinning
that is that has been developed for
millennial millennia then they they're
they're creating monsters they're
frankenstein uh
creations
we're in total agreement about that by
the way right
but so so i what i what i believe
is that
i i believe that
let's say for me that's like being the
best christian i can be and and living
with my family and my neighbors and the
people around me in the best way that's
the first best thing i can do right
that's really the first best thing i can
do and then obviously taking for taking
seriously the teachings of christ which
is you know to to to love your neighbor
to love your enemy to to not you know
to not to do unto others as as you would
want them to do unto you that's also
important but the the way it happens is
fractal it's not it's not i don't think
it's
it's in creating a kind of tower of
babel i think it happens it happens
but let's say in a certain manner it
happens kind of bottom up where as these
communities come together and in truth
and in love and in beauty then that
creates
new patterns patterns that other people
can replicate and then those patterns
get replicated
uh
it seems that that's what how it
happened in the first place let's say if
you think of
even the way that christianity spread
that's how it it happened you had people
who
exemplified patterned living and that at
first people hated them for it were
angry with them but then that ended up
acting like seeds which replicated
itself in other communities because they
could see the good that it was bringing
but it happened that way rather than
like saying we're all going to get
together and we're going to agree
right we're going to consciously agree
on a way forward towards the future
that to me sounds like what people are
trying to do now and what i see
coming from it like the great reset and
all that kind of stuff is frightening as
hell oh it's a disaster it's a terrible
disaster and you're not wrong about it
and you're not wrong that what i'm
arguing um
loosely fits in that same category right
but here's the here's the problem i know
i now think i i can see i don't know if
i can convey it but i think i can see
what the important thing we have to get
to is
um and it it
it's going to come in two forms the
first thing i have to say is we are
absolutely damned if we do and damned if
we don't okay that is the fundamental
nature of the predicament that i'm
trying to describe
um and i don't like it but that's where
we are as far as i can tell and the
other thing is the mechanism you just
described for how we got here
can not be the mechanism that we use to
get out of here as much as that may
sound like a paradox that got us this
far if we continue to use it it'll be
our undoing
so
i take the mechanism that got us here as
the evolution of these religious
traditions and my point is the evolution
of those religious traditions will cross
through extinction
that mechanism if we continue to allow
it to drive
will drive us extinct
the alternative is terrible which is
what you're saying right i don't
disagree with you about this but i think
we have to confront it and the point is
religions
every adaptation
right forget whether it's religion or an
eye or a wing or a leaf
every adaptation
is
useful
relative
to the environment in which it evolved
right a fish may be beautifully evolved
to swim on a reef it is terribly evolved
in the bottom of the boat
right in the bottom of the boat it's
a catastrophe of inappropriate tools
right
so
my point would be the religions that
brought us here are adaptive
or they were adaptive in the world in
which they came about
our world is now changing so rapidly and
is composed of so many things that those
religions did not foresee in any
specific sense
that
we are i think they did though
i really do think they did i really do
think they did for see what's going on
well they foresee certain things and you
know you point out like you know twitter
is the golem that we unleash on the
world and they didn't know what they
were doing and i agree at that level yes
they foresaw something but they didn't
foresee the splitting of the atom
they didn't foresee the evolution of
algorithms right not specifically enough
to be
instructive
and so
here's the problem
we are stuck with an infinite regress of
chesterton's fence
right we know if i'm right about what
religions are that they are adaptive
compendiums of wisdom
we are stuck
with the fact that there is no
you know when you program a computer you
put comments next to the lines you say
this
this function is supposed to accomplish
this thing that's why i put it here
right here are the arguments you submit
to this function you say that in english
so that somebody else can come into your
program and say ah that's the job this
is doing
religion doesn't come with that
right you get the program in the bibles
but you don't get the explanation of how
you know i think i can explain why a
belief in heaven is adaptive but it's
not explained anywhere
there's an entire tradition of theology
and church fathers that do exactly that
well they may be trying to reverse
engineer it
um and there was certainly a a tradition
that attempted to reconcile
you know modern scientific thought with
religious thought you know i i take no
position on that but my point is
if we are if we are handed
ancient compendiums of wisdom
in a modern world in which some of the
things in those compendiums are as
relevant as ever some of the things in
those compendiums are now irrelevant and
some of the things in those compendiums
are the opposite of useful right they
have gone from useful to dangerous
because of the change in the world we
live in
then we could
try to figure out
which pieces are in what category which
is liable to be
an error-prone
exercise
dangerous in its own right and very slow
we could try to substitute something new
which will not have the benefit of
having passed the test of time and
therefore we will end up with the
problems of wokism or
you know a covid
health policy right we will make error
after error
so my point is neither of those is a
survivable program
so we have to do some third thing right
where
a friend of mine coined the term that
what we have is we have to provide
something that fits a religion-shaped
whole
that there is a hole in our
being
that
needs something of this form
that the ancient religions put us in
danger because they're not up to speed
on modern problems and novel religions
are effectively cults until they pass
the test of time and we don't have the
luxury of exposing them to the test of
time so it's that third thing that we
need to find
yeah i mean i i guess our disagreement
is very fundamental like i think it's
it's it's fundamental because i really
do believe that
uh religion has set
let's say has described exactly what
we're going through not in terms of the
gritty detail but in terms of pattern
that is this is what we're talking about
from the outset we're talking about
patterns so there are patterns in cells
there are patterns in
in dna there are patterns in human
behavior and there are great patterns
there are large large patterns of of uh
let's say
waxing and wanings of civilizations
waxing wanings of different identities
and when we look at both let's say the
stories in scripture the prophetic text
we see that they're describing these
patterns
and if you're if we have the wisdom to
see them as patterns then we don't have
to think even about the splitting of the
atom because let's say a description of
the pattern of excessive technical
growth
and excessive technical understanding
the danger of secret understanding and
how that unleashes destruction on the
world is something which has been
described in many many religious texts
so then so then you're telling me that
uh the wisdom that we already have
points in a luddite direction
no not necessarily because the ultimate
vision of the end of of all things is
like i said the heavenly jerusalem which
is a perfect joining of technical
reality
and
the garden you could say right it's all
about it's all about hierarchy it's all
about having it in the right order
one of the issues we have is the issue
of materialism being in the wrong order
that is what we see material gain and
technical gain as being the god itself
that is we we
we run after it without with abandon we
don't have a sense in which we have to
to judge on the value and the ultimate
danger of these scientific discoveries
we just like run amok and then all of a
sudden we realize the chaos which it's
bringing but that's that is because of a
problem of hierarchy yeah because we
because we're not turned towards
infinite love as the source of all
things and we don't see that the the
tools we set out in the world have to be
bound by that
that that attention that we bound by
that first direction and so that's
something which is described everywhere
like it's okay but it's described in
it's not operationalizable
okay so let's take the obvious example
uh
from
the recent past okay
gain of function research on viruses
this is a
clear danger which you i think
will correctly describe as uh
presaged by religious admonitions about
technology okay well not just technology
but also uh that's a mixture of identity
you see that in in the old testament
laws and you see it in descriptions of
the developing of chimera that happened
you know cool before the flood let's say
that kind of description okay that kind
of story there's a warning if you know
how to read it in more than one
religious
text
about
something like gain of function research
maybe that thing being encoded in our
cultural
identity
is the reason that in 2015
the us congress
sought to ban gain of function research
and then
anthony fauci and peter dasik figured
out a way around this in which they
offshored the work to wuhan
wuhan
somehow
even if the right idea made it to the
right place to make the law to forbid
the behavior we still ended up happening
yeah it happened anyways so my point is
it's one thing
when that happens with uh
you know
first century technologies
it's another
thing when it happens with
you know 21st century
technologies
and it's the 20th 21st century
technologies that are
giving me the sense of urgency that we
have
what's more let me just put one more
thing on the table
let's take i i believe
that it is true
that
fusion power based on uranium is a dead
end
i could argue why that is but let's put
that for another time let's just say
there are problems with uranium-based
fission power that i believe are
insurmountable in the foreseeable future
whereas fusion power which is very
difficult which we have not yet usefully
generated electricity with
right we haven't gotten a
self-sustaining fusion reaction uh good
enough to be scaled up but
likely
the salvation of humanity depends
on us achieving that
right and therefore freeing ourselves
from battling over things like fossil
fuels but we don't yet have the wisdom
to deploy it if you deployed fusion
power if we discovered it tomorrow and
we just deployed it under
current uh political regimes it would
compound our problems
yeah probably
okay so let's say that those things are
true
they don't have to be true for the
purposes of this argument but they could
be true right if they are true
we don't have the
wisdom in the religious texts that
you're talking about or the religious
traditions from which they come
to know how to navigate our way away
from uranium fission and towards fusion
power with an upgraded political
modality that would allow us to deploy
it safely yeah religion offers the
reason it offers the reason why you'd
want to do that religion offers
the the the notion that if you
attend to the highest good
then the then you will make the right
decisions downstream but if you all you
care about is that everybody has two
cards and
and and and is materially comfortable if
that's if that's the purpose then you're
already not attending to the highest
good
right that's already the the problem is
already there at the outset which is
that one of the problems of the modern
world is that we think that material
comfort
and i say that like i i live in a house
like i you know i live with modern
material comfort but that we believe
that material comfort is
is good itself
and that and that's what is causing
the biggest problem
because it's a huge problem what you're
saying but the bigger problem that the
bigger problem is that if we continue to
act as if
material
good is the only good
then
there's no way that billions of people
in the world can all have two cars and a
pool and uh air-conditioned house like
we know that that's not that's not
scalable
and so there's actually a problem of of
value it's there's a problem of value
which will then downstream make us
decide differently if we
are aligned properly there's a great
story about a
about a chinese emperor who started to
um
create these fleets of boats that went
out all around the world and started to
trade in africa and all around the world
and then one day the emperor you know
walked out of his home and looked around
and saw the force were being depleted
and then he said stop
stop all of it
because
the the the purpose of getting material
wealth isn't enough to justify what i'm
doing there is a higher good which is
the very existence of my own
my country my people you know my my my
that's higher and so
this is this is what i that's why i'm
saying that i think that it's all there
in
in the religious story it's not gonna
technically tell you how to master this
or that this or that technology that's
for sure but it's going to give you the
direction
yeah but here's here okay
here's the problem
uh let's
let's coin a term
the atheist's advantage
the religious texts
function
when people accept them as true
right so i will make the argument that
if you behave
so that a christian text tells you that
your soul will get into heaven
that there isn't actually literally a
heaven but that the analog that you will
achieve is that you will
put your descendants in a better
position where they are more likely to
thrive right so that heaven is a
stand-in for the thriving of your
descendants okay
now the problem is
heaven
is a reward right you're told if you
behave in this way then you will
experience this glorious transcendent
uh
existence
yeah i mean
i don't think at least at least
initially that's not what heaven is and
it's also not the way that
religion the way religion works is that
it's it's it's fractally structured
which means that the way that it
describes reality is available to the
highest mystical thinker and and the
lowest you know like illiterate peasant
and so if you you'll say something like
that probably to the illiterate peasant
but that's not that's not how the great
sages of christianity thought of what
what heaven was well i will argue that
that does not matter
that the point is it will the story will
function at whatever level is needed for
each
level of enlightenment and that's fine
but it's not less true what you tell the
peasant isn't less true
right the point is it's true at each
person at the level that they need it
right so if the peasant believes if i
behave well then i will experience this
glorious existence after i die and if i
behave badly it will be all pain
every day forever right
those are strong motivators
they adjust behavior
and the problem is
an atheist
who realizes
that isn't exactly true
right i can do bad things and
the worst from the point of view of my
actual self
my suffering ends on my death
right i may profit but even if i screw
it up the suffer the suffering is finite
right that individual has an advantage
in terms of getting ahead the advantage
comes at the expense of the lineage
now my point is
that
advantage
explains much of the way the world
functions now because people have but
that's because they don't have access to
the they haven't accessed the higher
part of the heaven story if they did
then they would realize that it's not
about doing good things and having let's
say
some afterlife or whatever what it is is
that is in the manner in which you exist
like it is your actual being being
transformed into something more right
that's going into heaven right which is
this transformation of consciousness up
the different levels
and that if you do that you will have a
better life
now like it's not right which is
actually right now which is actually a
pretty good match for the way
i would think most jews
most religious jews view it right not so
much about going to heaven
but uh about
the nature of your existence but
never mind i think the point is
the what you're describing is the more
enlightened way of viewing
the story of heaven
is concordant with my way of viewing
this as a non-religious person
which is
actually
my
obligation
is to provide
this opportunity in an undergraded form
maybe even an enhanced form
to distant descendants
whose name i will never know
right so the point is those things are
compatible with each other but what they
are not
is
packaged in a way that incentivizes
people to behave so as to protect the
well-being of their distant descendant
right but you don't act i mean if you
tell me that you act to protect your
descendants to you know thousands of
years from now i don't think that's true
like i think you can abstractly think
though i do but it's not true in your
everyday experience
according to these immediate desires
like i i behave this way but i am inept
at it
right i am inept at it i'm like the
sculptor trying to make mount rushmore
with a chisel
right i i don't have the tools because
nothing evolution gave me tools that
aren't good at this job and religions
are adapted to an environment too early
to be useful in this regard and so my
attempt to protect my descendants 10 000
years from now are admittedly
probably close to pointless because i
don't have the wisdom to do it well but
what if to protect your descendants 10
000 years from now you had to engage in
a way of being that would also be the
best way of being for you now
like that would it would be objectively
be the best way of existing you know
which would be to live a life of of love
of love of your neighbor a life of let's
say uh
true self sacrifice where you're able to
render up your kind of immediate chaotic
desires that kind of appear all over the
place your desire to get this or to do
this and to sacrifice them towards a
higher purpose and if you did that you
would actually be not only enlightened
but you would also
let's say
open up the possibility of your
descendants you know whatever thousands
of years from now to to have the best
life that you can afford them i think
not only by perpetuating your your your
genes but by perpetuating modes of being
around you that will per that will also
reproduce themselves
in the future so it's not just about
your genes like it it also is about the
manner in which you live which ripples
out around you and your family and your
kids in your in your neighborhood and
then creates new patterns of being that
that reproduce themselves at their level
as well
i think so that's what religion that's
what religion is religion is that i i
don't disagree with you but but the
place that we disagree is that i think
the likelihood that
living
as a religious tradition would have me
live
um
is the best thing i can do for my
descendants ten thousand years from now
chances of that being true
are a million to one
right but i i don't think you think
about your descendants i'm thinking i'm
sorry to say like
thinking about him right now abstractly
but when you're drinking water and when
you're
you know when you're taking a bath or
when you're living your life like you're
you're you're not living you know when
you're hugging your kids you're you ha
there's a level of experience which is
more
immediate and is more accessible of
course than your descendants 10 000
years from now of course it can't help
it can't help but be the case
um don't you think there could be a way
in which all of these could stack up
like a way of being in which these would
stack you don't think so no i mean look
frankly i think the best thing i can do
for my descendants ten thousand years
from now is have conversations with
people like you that hopefully will
function as a bat signal for other
people who see the same problem will
cause people who see a flaw in my
reasoning to make themselves known and
pointed out
the chances that it's sufficient to
actually have the effect are pretty low
i'm not arguing that i think
i'm making headway on the puzzle but i
do think
that i am behaving
with the intention of maximizing i think
very little that we do
in the present
matters to 10 000 years from now because
we are so clearly on a path to
extinction right and so what about the
the the strategy that has been given
let's say in different traditional uh
different religions of the building of
an ark
pattern
which is that you see that the idea of
the remnant you see that in scripture
quite a bit where there are cycles of
collapse and success in scripture and
usually as you approach the collapse you
have something like a a remnant which
then continues on into the future and
then let's say restarts the cycle this
is yeah i mean obviously that noah's ark
is the the biggest example of that but
there are several examples of that
uh in in history this is exactly the
point um
i am a believer that you build the ark
under sunny skies and people think
you're a fool and then it starts raining
and they start building but it's too
late okay
um so i agree that that has been the
pattern and while i don't believe in a
literal
uh flood story and noah and his arc i do
believe that it's a metaphor for
important things that are real
on the other hand
i also know that while nobody was
looking or thinking about it in
particularly religious terms we built
400 civilian nuclear reactors
that require constant electrical
vigilance in order to keep them cool
enough not to turn into nuclear
volcanoes and at the point
that the collapse as you describe it
comes which is effectively inevitable
those things will
severely degrade the planet if not
render it uninhabitable
and so the point is
the idea i believe there have been
collapse after collapse after collapse
and that do you think this one is so big
that it could actually completely
destroy all life i think it's almost
certain and not you know i've given you
one mechanism by which the earth will be
severely degraded and there will be no
recovering it even if humanity survives
it will be a very much lesser world
right
and that this is not the only one of
these we have seen
you know that none of them have been at
the right scale to
to properly shock us but we have seen
you know
fukushima
we have seen the deepwater horizon
accident the elizo canyon
uh
leak we have seen the financial collapse
of 2008 and now we have seen
uh kovid emerge very probably from a lab
in wuhan
all of these
are the same pattern again and again
where human beings are playing with a
kind of power
that we only understand the devastation
that can come from it after the horses
have left the barn right yeah now the
problem is
so far as i know i'm the only person
who's writing that list
that list says hey there's a meta
problem right you know the financial
collapse of 2008 and kovid 19 are the
same problem they're the same problem as
fukushima yeah no i totally agree
and so the point is we don't have a
religious text that deals with that
level of hazard where a small number of
individuals can make decisions for all
of us at a scale that's almost
impossible to imagine yeah but i do
think that the flood story is exact is
exactly that and especially the other
traditions like you you might want to
you're if you're interested that you
might want to look into the enoki and
tradition so the
the
traditions of enoch you had a sense that
before the flood before noah
these um
these people got into contact with uh
demons with fallen angels
and the fallen angels taught them skills
different skills skills to modify the
world skill to make chimera skills to
create weapons skills to create all
these things but also let's say magical
skills to transform reality obviously
this is describing it in that in that
sense and that these practices
are what led to the flood itself
um and so the the the the coming into so
let me describe it in the secular way if
it's struggling with the angels and the
demons whatever it's like
encountering in certain ways patterns
which are
higher but are too
difficult and we don't understand the
all the ramifications of those patterns
and then we embody them in the world
and so we create things like nuclear
weapons we create we don't understand
all the ramifications of the patterns
that we're encountering we embody them
and therefore they bring about calamity
and collapse
and that the only way to
get out of that at once the ball is
rolling like the only manner to do that
is
to have something like like an arc
there's no other way because
you know and i think that that's what's
being described also at the notion of
the end of times like this idea of the
end of the world which is part of almost
all religions have a sense in which at
some point it's all going to collapse
like it's all of this is going to break
apart
uh but that that it's almost like we're
not going to reverse it by now it's not
it's not like we're going to
but we have to rather find ways to
plant seeds and to or to gather seeds
maybe is the best way to understand it
rather than just plant them to gather
them
uh seeds of wisdom and also seeds of
being all of these things together okay
so i i think i i think i got it
i don't disagree with you that the
problem is anticipated
right and that the place that the
problem is anticipated is in religious
texts
i do not believe that it is anticipated
with
technically let's say the technical part
of it i don't even care about the
technical part i don't think it is
sufficiently
anticipated
that
those texts provide us a meaningful
guide as to what to do in other words
i think
we just
loaded the ark
with nitrogen-based fertilizer and
fireworks and we're smoking on the deck
right
that's what we did
and
i don't think we have the proper terror
because at some level because religions
are targeted at
talking to individuals
right we don't understand you know we
all know we're gonna die
and so the idea that we're behaving in a
foolish way that may bring about our
death early
isn't sufficiently terrifying
we don't have the architecture
to be terrified enough that we may bring
our lineage the human lineage to an end
right that would be such a terrible
tragedy to do any earlier than has to
happen
and yet we are
recklessly playing
with exactly the tools that we'll bring
it about not only earlier than it has to
happen but soon
right and so
the point is somehow we have those
religious texts and they're not working
and they're not working for a reason and
i don't think a
return to those texts is plausible
i don't think were there a major return
to those texts that it would cause
people to awaken to the danger that
we're putting humanity
into but i do think that those who
deeply understand those texts could
be brought to a recognition that
actually
um
they need to update them
this is that moment
yeah i mean i don't i'm not sure i
understand what that means in the sense
of or re reapply them is
and it's not just text like i'm not i'm
not protestant
it's not a question of text it's a
question of of ways of being and ways of
existing and and manners of
you know
let's say hierarchies of attention and
hierarchies of virtues these are the
things which we live in you know texts
are important i i love the bible i think
it's great but i i don't think that
that's what religions aren't texts they
are their ways of being in ways of
existing in ways of of of encountering
others and i think that
that i think that exactly in there
that's where the solution is the
solution is not a technical one the the
only solution we can find is a wisdom
one it is to engage
better ways of being better ways of
encountering each other like like what
we're doing here right yep we are
encountering each other in a manner
which
is is not confrontational it's not there
to just to trick the other person or to
to lead them into a corner or whatever
and so i think that that's a that is an
image of let's say
love and practice right love and
embodied and so these are the types of
things you have to do but at every level
like at every level that we can muster
and that's the
and so
to me that's the only solution
like there is the idea of like
re-adapting religion you know i don't i
can i can see why someone who's secular
would would want that because
like there's a kind of disdain towards
religious practice and disdain there's a
there's a sense in which i'll have a lot
of it is superstitious or a lot of it
doesn't make sense not from me not for
me that's not how i feel i just think
it's not up to the challenge
believe me if i thought that the
solution to the problem that we've
described
was uh
a fundamentally
religious approach or a
dusting off of texts or a
re-energizing of patterns of interaction
that come from there i'd be all for it
because i am concerned about
you know i'm not really that concerned
about my ancestors 10 000 years from now
because i don't think we're gonna get
anywhere close to that right i think
we've got a problem on the scale of the
next hundred years
um
but nonetheless if i thought that the
solution
involved some tool that we already have
i would be all for it because i do think
that this is the most important moral
problem that we have and that people are
not
they are not properly frightened of the
loss that comes from the destruction of
lineage precisely because
the destruction of lineage in the past
didn't mean the end of your species
it has never meant that until now and
so you know i'm not rejecting anything
on the basis of it being you know i know
how scientists dismiss religion and i've
never been about that um but believe me
i'm i'm for whatever tool works in this
case so that people you know a hundred
years from now can look back on us and
say here's what they got wrong and my
fear is that there will be no one to
look back
but maybe maybe the the the mistake is
the tool part like i think that that's
the mistake the mistake is on is looking
for tools because
the the let's say the religious the
wisdom and the religious point of view
are the
the mythical point of view in which
we sit and we're capable of seeing
that which is good
it's not a tool
right it's actually a way of being and
the way of being is is the is the manner
in which you're going to be able to even
see that what's going on is a problem
and so it's not it's not about a bunch
of tools the tools will come adapted to
the situation but what it requires first
is a is a direction and a mode of being
and the thing is i think that both of us
agree
on the direction and the mode of being
it's just that i'm trying what i what i
what i i'm trying to express is that
that mode of being is already
a religious mode of being like the
the turning your eyes towards the good
and to the
notion of something like infinite love
as the source of true being that's
already a religious position
and then downstream from that are
different things for example a hierarchy
of virtues a hierarchy of values than a
manner in which we engage with others
and then down scale from that even then
you'll have specific things like the way
we light candles or the way we you know
we go to certain buildings to worship
but
there is a hierarchy in in those things
and and i think that already at the
outset
is already a
it's already a worshipful stance you're
already standing in a place in which
you're attending to and you're
celebrating the highest good
and you're saying everybody we need to
look in that direction and then the
tools will come
after
if we think about tools then we're going
to scram we're going to be running
around trying to put patch in all these
different holes that are leaking
but it's like that you first of all need
to
realize let's say what is it that we are
what is it that we want
ultimately what is the highest good and
then we'll develop tools to to fix them
but the problem i think now is mostly
that we have we've lost even the bearing
of what is good
like we've even lost the bearing of what
is the highest good what is it that we
and honestly i don't think that it's the
continuation of lineage
that is we can't think that way human
beings don't don't
interact at that level even though i
understand why you do we don't nobody
lives at the level of of like the
defense of lineage people live at a more
immediate
scale no no no this this is this is so
first of all by tool i don't mean to
limit
what could fit in that category
consciousness is a tool um
but do people live in such a way as to
defend their lineage they do
it is religious that's what has done it
right and so the point is
for you
when a religion tells maybe it's a
peasant
that if you behave to a certain standard
then your soul will live forever in a
glorious state
right when you tell somebody that it is
a mechanism to get them to correct their
behavior so that their lineage will
continue indefinitely that's what i'm
arguing it is it is that tool in
disguise
right and it has been
vitally important in getting our
lineages to this point in history
where it is now failing because the
atheists are taking advantage of the
fact that they don't have their behavior
restricted in this way
yeah
i mean i understand why you see it at
that level but i
i think i would tend to see the the
perpetuation of the lydia as something
which is downstream from what it really
is which is engaging the best mode of
being for now and for your entire being
and and then downstream from that is
something like so let's say okay so how
about this
even in evolutionary terms wouldn't you
say that
the the preservation of self comes
before the preservation of lineage
i don't think so no
no i i remember before my first child
was born
actually i think it literally may have
been the night before my first child was
born i obviously knew he was coming
i remember
my mind
in some
pattern of sleep and then wake i
remember my mind reorganizing itself
over the idea that someone was arriving
in the world for whom i might have to
trade my life right okay i understand in
that sense yeah definitely no i totally
agree with you i think i missed step
there when i the way i said it what i
mean is that
there is
let's say there is a manner in which a
mode of being
that that i have and let's say i could
especially for a direct relationship of
my child to willing to sacrifice myself
for my child or for my neighbors or for
something which is immediate in my
experience my nation my but this is what
i this is the level in which i live it
this is the level of description
in which story narrative ritual
religious is
described and i think that that's the
truer and the first
reality
and downstream from that you would have
something like
a blessing will fall upon your children
right you see that in scripture like a
blessing will
to the 10th within the thousands
generation the blessing will will fall
upon your children something like that
but but that it's
but that the way that you describe
things i think there's an abstraction
that's going on and you you move between
an abstraction of let's say lineage
protection
and then
a more immediate
idea of a perception of that which is
good because again like even because we
talked about it before like what we
think
is
the highest good for example and the
idea that we need to
let's say upend the genes to a certain
extent and that's someone who's not
thinking only about the preservation of
his lineage there's something else going
on like there's another virtue another
value which is pulling you forward which
is which is higher than the the one
which says i want my genes to perpetuate
themselves
ten thousand years let's say
and i think that that's at the religious
level we are at a religious level when
we're there when we're talking about
that
and so the idea of avoiding it or to try
to
reinterpret it or whatever i don't see
how it's going to be helpful because
it's there like that's the level we're
at um and i agree that the atheist is a
serious is a
the atheist in the system like that
is a problem or someone who
someone who's cynical like is a is a
problem in in a system like that uh
but i it's i don't know like how long
can i i mean you're right it could last
long enough for us to destroy the
destroy most life let's say on earth so
yeah
yeah you're right that that doesn't end
up being a problem it's it's a problem
so yeah two things one i i sort of see
myself as somebody who has built up a
toolkit for evolution
for understanding evolution that i don't
think is useful to most people might be
sort of interesting at the level of a
curiosity but it's not something
most people will would have used for
but i can use it and i can go
look
at
there's a place i can go stand because
of the religious
religious because of the
evolutionary toolkit i've built up
and i can look back at humanity and i
can say ah that's where we are got it
and then i can come back and i can try
to have conversation with people who
have different toolkits from where they
see
humanity and so i'm trying to call
attention to something
i don't know if it's uniquely visible
from that place i can go visit but you
can see it from that point i can see it
and it's really clear right we have a
problem in the immediate present and
that problem
is
couldn't be more philosophically
profound if it tried it's it's the
biggest problem anyone's ever had that's
the thing right the extinction of
humanity is almost by definition the
biggest problem anyone ever had and we
have it right
and so
anyway i'm trying to alert people to
that thing and that you know yeah
we've got to we've got to make a mount
rushmore all we've got are chisels let's
figure out do we have anything else that
we could you know
turn into something of the appropriate
scale to be able to address our problem
i don't know
okay the final thing i want to say is
i have an example of uh
literally false metaphorically true that
i think
i like it because it
there are no stakes to it um
but i think it actually
explains maybe you'll see in it the
answer to the question that you you keep
posing to me
the example is
the idea of follow-through for a person
playing baseball when they're batting or
a tennis player hitting the ball right
we say it is very important
that you follow through on the hit right
now physically speaking it is not
it actually has no impact on the ball
right once the ball has left the racket
the follow through is irrelevant
but it is vitally important that you
prepare to follow through and that you
not stop following through right up
through the moment that you hit the ball
right so the easiest way to get somebody
to do this is say follow through it's
very important that you follow through
it's not literally true but it's
metaphorically true if you behave as if
you if you behave in a way that you
follow through then everything you do up
to the point that it stops mattering
will be right
okay
and so my point would be
that
the
the issue you raise
about having to live in the present
and the issue i raise about what happens
ten thousand years from now
go through this example
right my point is it is very important
that we live in such a way that there is
a future for our descendants 10 000
years from now
and
we don't have any influence directly
over 10 000 years from now the influence
we have is right up through where we hit
the ball right and that's where religion
functions well it has traditionally told
people how to live in the present right
that's the moment of hitting the ball
right and it has
by virtue of what it has by virtue of
the danger that people have posed to
their own lineages
it has given pretty good guidance about
how to live in that moment where you hit
the ball but we are now dealing with a
puzzle in which hitting the ball as we
are presently empowered to do it means
there will be no game ten thousand years
from now maybe not even
a hundred years from now and
so that's that's why i'm
uh
i think
challenging your notion that yes we we
have the tools we need already
and we just need to use them because i
don't think the tools are up to that job
yeah
um
so
i'm trying to to
to jump into your example like
let's say you have the tennis player and
you're saying you could
you would say something else because
you would say i don't know what is it
you would say except follow through
right you say follow through and then
the the gesture happens and
in the way that you're describing
there are things looming on us like a
great catastrophe let's say
and so we're moving towards that
catastrophe
and
in my opinion we are moving towards that
catastrophe precisely because
we stopped telling
the tennis player to follow through
that's why we're going in that direction
because we said hey you know what
it doesn't matter if you follow through
or not it doesn't matter because it's
not true it's false it's fake like it's
it's a trick it's there to control you
saying follow through is a superstition
it's all of that stuff that we said and
so we told the tennis player stop doing
that
and now we're losing the game
and so now we're losing the game and
you're saying well the game is in such a
dire place
that we have to now make up a new
mechanism
you know
in order to win the game or to not lose
the game
uh and i'm thinking okay
i mean you know good luck with that
maybe i don't know i don't know what
else to say except that like at least
saying follow through
was was was true and was going to make
you win the game yeah no you're not
wrong about that i i agree with this
that we surrendered a lot of really
useful stuff
as something else happened and
you know for the third time in this
conversation i sort of think i think i
now see it
okay
the problem is
i look at religion as composed of
various things right there are
the
descriptions of how one is to live
that are the heart of the matter right
that's the the adaptive part
right and then there is a bunch of
structure necessary to make that part
work
right so sort of the way
a bicycle frame the only purpose of the
bicycle frame is to hold the other parts
in the right place to do the job of the
bicycle right
the trunk of a tree is not productive
the trunk of a tree elevates the leaves
to a place where they can compete for
light so the trunk is a cost
it's a cost you can't avoid but it is
not itself productive right
and there's a bunch of stuff in
religious
doctrine
that has that role right so
a description of where the universe came
from and when
is not necessary to know how to behave
right but it got written in there
and the problem is because it's easily
shown to be literally false
it causes
a cynicism about the parts of the
tradition that are useful
right it causes people to reject the
descriptions of the limits that they
should have to their behavior for
example
and
so
my concern is okay we stopped telling
people to follow through because follow
through was not a literally true
description of something that was
necessary and that was a mistake because
planning to follow through is as
important as it ever was
right
but the problem is
because so much of what sold people
on religion was the fact that it
answered ultimately unanswerable
questions and then the payoff came in
the fact that the same thing that told
you where the universe came from also
told you how to behave and if you
behaved that way it was actually good
even if you couldn't explain why
the problem is
that we are now in a position where to
do science
is to show that elements of these
compendiums of wisdom are just wrong
and that causes people to abandon the
part that really matters which is the
how am i to behave part
right
and so i'm not sure how you solve that
problem in a scientific era
well
i don't think i don't find it difficult
to solve at all because
there's a difference between technical
descriptions and narrative descriptions
there just are right if i'm making a
narrative description a technical
description of a car i'm not doing the
same thing as telling you you know to
get in the car and go to the store and
buy some milk like those two things are
completely different they're just not in
the same they just they're not in the
same sphere right and so if if i
understand that scripture
is describing the reality in which you
live
the reality in which you act the reality
in which you deal with others that's
what it's describing it's not even
trying to describe a scientific thing
it's not trying to describe a technical
thing so because of that i can take for
example like you talked about the
creation narrative the creation
narrative of scripture is one of the
most profound and powerful text that has
ever been
uh composed it's just that if you see it
as a
as a as the as the equivalent of
describing the the biological makeup of
this or that thing
then you are then you're obviously going
to not see it for what it is but if you
see it as describing a pattern of being
then then then we're good to go and
we're good to go and if you read the
text you'll notice that it's about
it's about speaking and about seeing and
about judging and deciding what is good
like that's what the text is about it
describes a pattern of being and then it
talks about recognizing that which is
good and and that's what it's that's
what it's doing so there are ways in
which we can go back into these texts
and just represent them to people in a
manner that says it's just not about
what some people thought it was like
it's not it's not it's not the same
thing as describing
you know i don't know like with the
parts of like i said the parts of a car
it's just not that
well i i agree with you it's not that's
not its
use
but it does describe certain things that
it turns out we now know aren't right
right and that this look
you know i
i'm not overly hung up on it
but i do think it is not surprising
that religion
is
only
loosely adhered to
by
a small fraction of the population
in an era
where
we have
the ability to understand
how species came to be
through a process of evolution where the
text tells us that actually each of
these creatures was specially designed
by a god right those two things are in
conflict
and i don't think they are at all but i
i don't think they're in conflict
because
for the same reason that for the same
reason that
the patterns of of being let's say for
the same reason that you're able to say
that you want to upend
the genes
for that same reason
that consciousness comes down upon
identities
and
frames them and defines them
so the idea that
so the idea that species exist without
consciousness
is is a very iffy shady thing like the
idea that there's a difference between
this or that dog
at a higher level than the individual
is a very contentious thing if you don't
understand that consciousness also
notices identities and participates in
their existence
and so the idea that consciousness comes
down on existence and
forms identities i don't think it's
something which is weird at all even for
even for someone who's who's let's say
just a little bit philosophically astute
and understands that
categories don't
just exist materially that they also
exist as this top-down noticing of
patterns and distinction of patterns i
don't i don't understand that
perspective because it seems to me if i
look back into the fossil record at
creatures that no longer
exist
i can make an inference
let me just let me just push you back on
that right away so
species are constantly evolving
yep so when do you decide that something
is a specie
and something is no longer that specie
oh and and and and and you'll you'll
give me an answer yeah for sure you'll
give me an answer but the idea that that
answer that answer is metaphysically
certain
well yeah
like the idea that the species that you
found that doesn't exist anymore
that that hasn't that it's not still the
species now it's like when people when
people say things like dinosaurs are
related to birds or something i always
think like what are you talking about
birds are dinosaurs right that that
saying something like that is
is very very contentious in terms of
understanding how identity works no no
no no no that's the beauty of lineage
right here's the thing you're a member
of every lineage you've ever been a
member of and the reason that i can say
birds are dinosaurs and not worry that
i'm just playing some definitional trick
is that if you take the ancestor
of all
dinosaurs right the first dinosaur right
and i'm not telling you you can know who
that creature is but i am telling you
there has to have been a dinosaur who
gave rise to all of the other dinosaurs
if you do that
you will find that birds are in that
lineage
right just like you're in the lineage of
things of like unicellular and if you're
any cellular being at some point so are
you a unicellular being
so
we can solve this problem if you want um
let's
take uh the lineage of tetrapods okay so
tetrapods are
um
the four
limbed descendants of
um
of vertebrates okay
not all tetrapods have four limbs right
the functional term is quadruped right
so a snake is a tetrapod that's a
phylogenetic designation it can't
doesn't matter that it's lost its limbs
because it's still a descendant of the
initial tetrapod but it's not a
quadruped right because it doesn't have
any limbs
so
the point is are we are we unicellular
organisms we are not one celled but we
are the descendant of a lineage right
that at its inception was one cell
so that's not a that's not a terribly
difficult problem to deal with it's a
linguistically annoying problem that we
keep tripping over
what i mean is that if if
species are constantly in flux yep and
then you cut
you cut into that flux right you say
this is a distinction and this is not a
distinction right right i agree and
that's arbitrary so it's not arbitrary
like no it is it's not arbitrary because
it has causal effect it has a causal it
then will causally affect the man in
which you
treat those beings and the man in which
you you deal with them the man in which
you everything about them is going to be
real
the man in which you deal with them it's
not going to be just arbitrary no no
those distinctions if we say well this
was an osteopathicine
right and that was uh
in the genus homo right if the
australopithecine is an ancestor of homo
we are making an arbitrary distinction
this is sufficiently different
to call it a new genus and i'm not
defending that right we can do it but we
have to recognize we are making an
arbitrary distinction when we do that we
are not making an arbitrary distinction
when we say this is a trilobite and that
is an arachnid
right when we say that we are actually
describing two different lineages
there's no judgment call to be made
assuming we've done the work correctly
we know that the trilobite is not an
arachnid right so when i look back in
the fossil record i'm not talking about
the linear progression and drawing
distinctions and claiming that they are
real i'm talking about looking at
distinct lineages and saying
uh you know that
the
the ammonite and the nautilus are part
of the same lineage and it is a distinct
lineage uh
from
uh
from
the beetle right so but brett what i
mean is that all beings
all beings that exist that you can
identify are both the same in some
aspect and different in another
every single being that you encounter
has something in common with all the
other beings and that is something
different from all the other beings so
there's a manner in which we cut into
that
we cut into that and we distinguish we
consciousness is capable of discerning
difference and and
let's say
joining patterns together in order to
say that those patterns are sufficiently
alike so that we recognize them as
having being yep and then seeing that
those patterns are not sufficiently like
for us to recognize that they have being
that they have different different
natures you could say and so
that's what if you want to understand
what what scripture is talking about
like that's what it's talking about ah
that's what we that's why we we we talk
about the notion that
that that god
differentiates
and then judges
whether something is good because you
could you i'm sure you could tell me
like the difference between
a good
member of one species from a not so good
member of one species you know you could
judge you could judge that for all the
reasons that you can but that's what
that's what scripture ultimately is
talking about
right so the idea that
so when you think that god
you think that if you struggle the idea
that god let's say
planned these identities and and created
all these beings
you have to realize that we do that to a
certain extent ourselves
at a limited level we do that that's
true i think the
the evolutionary toolkit allows us to
define why things fall under a
definition of a pattern right and the
maybe one of the key insights is that
there are multiple reasons
why two things would fall into the same
pattern one is that they share an
ancestor from whom they inherited that
pattern the other is that they have
converged on a solution from two
different starting points and we see
both of these things intermingled
they're both but that one is super
interesting because focusing on lineage
is one thing but noticing analogy
between functions is another and now
we're really closer to religious
speaking now we're really closer to the
notion that we can recognize identity
and purpose and that identity and
purpose can be recognized in different
mechanical causes that i can see the
things that have different mechanical
origins or different let's say
physical origins can share a common
purpose and it's like value in religious
language now you're in like the idea
that god created things already like
you're already in that world
so i know maybe you don't don't totally
follow where i'm bringing you no i think
i do i think i do and uh you know i'm
uh
i hope it is
fair to say um
you know i feel
you've taken me a bit down the road to
see
your perspective here i hope i have done
the same for you and i feel
certain that this is the first of
several conversations we're gonna need
to have we've been going we've been
going for three hours i don't think i've
ever had
as long a conversation as this i don't
think it's three hours but uh it's
certainly gonna be two
yeah um
oh we started you started one and it was
four
well see now you must be in a different
time zone because it's it's not four
here all right
um
uh so how about we put it on pause here
i would i would love i think that we're
in an interesting place and i would love
to continue the conversation because i i
i think you're definitely put i know i
knew that you would be the person that
could push me in my mind in directions
that i would be scrambling to find
ground and so i love that like i love
that feeling and i love the fact that
we're able to do it without
ill intent and not trying to to to
squeeze the other or whatever so i
appreciate it nothing but affection for
you man i i really appreciate the way
you approached this and i knew i knew it
was going to be a great conversation and
i should have seen that it was going to
be an unfinished conversation coming
that was all right i would love to i
would love to set up another
conversation like this great let's do it
um in the meantime where can people find
you
all right so people are interested in
what i'm doing you can go to the
symbolicworld.com
and that's usually where most of my
stuff my stuff is my videos you also
have people writing articles different
people participating in this kind of
community uh so that's the best place to
go okay
you're also on twitter yes i'm on
twitter at jonathan
i think it's pedro jonathan when i'm on
twitter it's a bad sign it means i'm not
oh okay well good we can watch you
misbehave on twitter and uh you've done
some really interesting conversations of
late you want to name a couple of the
ones you've done so people can go look
at those
yeah definitely if you're interested you
can go on jordan peterson's channel
we've had some very interesting
conversations recently on that channel
especially with john vervicky and bishop
baron
you know just
there's been some very good
some very good moments of kind of coming
together and so i hope maybe i'm going
to talk to sam harris i don't know it's
it's being talked about that would be
nice and so there are some also
interesting conversations coming in the
future all right cool all right well
jonathan pajo it's been a real pleasure
and i'm looking forward to picking up
the conversation soon all right brett
thanks thanks for the opportunity yep be
well